françoise s'est pas trop déçu par le
résultat des élections de dimanche
dernier
si bien sûr c'est toujours décevant de
constater que que la démagogie et la
fourberie fonctionne mieux que résister
je maintiens les gens fonctionnent mais
à françois mitterrand tellement bas
c'est ouais c'était pour bart combat
pour chirac aux 681 à voter chirac
je ne me souviens pas avant je te dis
cela s'est fait dans libération dix
jours après les élections
oui c'est possible j'ai 26 ans je pense
que c'est mauvais pour la france et
l'élection de mitterrand
je ne connais pas assez la politique
l'économie pour pour savoir ce qui parce
que si c'est bon si c'est mauvais
j'aurais préféré effectivement que
l'équipe chirac ou qui parce qu'elle
fait ses preuves et qu'elle avait l'air
particulièrement dynamique
j'ai pas du tout envie de retrouver la
clique qu'on arrive en 81 kg comment tu
expliques que la plupart des artistes
surtout mitterrand donc je renseigne
question dans ça ne mange pas julien
clerc et les vétérans les conditions
socio culturel moi c'est pas humain en
somme un milieu très modeste il pense
pas que ça va être très utile c'est
comme ça reste comme ça tu penses pas
que ça peut créer du tort de dire des
trucs comme ça la clé
tu me demandes des choses je peux dire
le contraire de ce qu'ils ont dans leurs
vidéos en 83 84 il avait un mauvais
passage
astral avait des ennuis dans son regard
a fait son thème astral pour les connais
son thème astral je sais quelle est sa
dominante et je sais que c'est une
dominante qui donne des des champions de
navigation en eaux troubles
ouais avant et qu'elle chérit scorpions
il ya surtout un pluton très très fort
un bon taux nhien et les plutonien sont
des gens vraiment
donc moi personnellement je me méfie des
cas pas eu la curiosité de regarder pour
les 7 ans qui viennent ce qui va se
passer mais je vais dire par rapport à
lui ouais
lui il a une échéance justement qu'il va
tout à fait à l'encontre de ces
tendances hymne est sûr que c'est
tendance innée se brouiller les pistes
et cela l'est dans plusieurs directions
longtemps là il faut vraiment qu'ils
prennent une direction claire et claire
et précise des personnalités socialistes
en vue c'est michel repères que les
échéances les plus importantes et bien
michel rocard contrairement à mitterrand
il est apparu sur sa personnalité le
porte avoir une ligne droite et il
suffit de quelques noms gauche alors il
ya 20 ans 68 arrêter la scène et un
temps plus tard par apple mais c'est pas
pour maintenant parce que ce n'était pas
prémédité l'arrêt de enfin arrêter la
scène s'était pas vraiment prêt visiter
sais que ça peut être un arrêt
temporaire
finalement c'est qu'un arrêt définitif
pour être vraiment bien dans la colonne
parce que tu as 44 ans pense que le
championnat c'est pas ça c'est que je
pense qu'on en a assez de se retrouver
dans l'église émission de télévision
avec les mêmes gens je parle même pas de
la première fois qu'une émission comme
celle ci mais c'est vrai que finalement
sur le plan de de la réalisation des
chansons et il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
progrès de fait je dirais même je tiens
même que celle inverse où il ya toujours
des exceptions j'ai participé l'a
récemment à une émission contraire je
vais des lumières magnifiques mais dans
l'ensemble c'est plutôt moins bien
qu'avant alors voudra pas envie de vous
donne de retomber dans ce stress parce
que c'est toujours très très stressante
show très difficile de se retrouver
comme ça devant
notre caméra à défendre une petite
chanson que l'outil qui n'est que ce
qu'admet c'est à dire d'une petite
chanson et en plus de savoir que les
gens qui sont en train de vous filmer
mais se trouve ou très mal construit à
penly tant pis si ça va j'ai zéro
maintenant tout va bien et puis quoi
c'est devenu une corvée pour toi c'est
ça de n'enregistrer corps des périodes
sans parler des plateaux même le studio
ces deux studios c'est quand même
beaucoup moins excitant pour moi
maintenant que ça n'était dans les
années 70 par exemple et que les
gestionnaires des machines
voilà il ya ça un petit peu qui fait que
bon c'est vrai que c'est moins
intéressant c'est vrai qu'il ya des
problèmes qui se posent moi je sais que
pour le dernier disque donc que je sais
c'est qu'ils sauront maintenant j'ai eu
des problèmes de justesse la première
fois de ma vie alors je j'ai pensé
d'abord que c'était parce que j'étais
fatigué ensuite je me suis dit que
c'était peut-être parce que les
instruments acoustiques n'était pas
accordé exactement la même façon que
d'un synthétique
il ya de toute façon un petit peu les
deux et la promo ça t'emmerde sinon
c'est ça ça m'ennuie pas vraiment de me
retrouver avec des journalistes par
exemple est donné de papoter avec un
parce que quelquefois il vous pose des
questions que vous ne vous posez pas que
vous ne vous seriez pas rezé qui vous
oblige à réfléchir à certaines choses
dans ce sens c'est toujours intéressant
mais ce qui m'ennuie
je peux pas faire de pourcentage à lui
dire une fois sur but mais en fait j'ai
peut-être plus c'est peut-être moi je ne
sais pas c'est quand je lis et quand je
nie leur article disons très exactement
ce que tu vois là on est très souvent
trahie et on est d'ailleurs loin - trahi
par les étrangers que par les français
curieuse où tu sens à 33 qui s'appelle
décalage qu'il a fait avec qui je les
fais avec un enfin avec beaucoup de gens
en priorité avec un ami qui s'appelle
journal chanéac composé 5 des musiques
et avec lequel j'avais déjà enregistré
vip enfin une chanson que sa plus
vieille puis il ya deux ans et qui a
coproduit donc cet album on l'a
enregistré avec des anglais pas mal avec
des musiciens anglais
le producteur nos producteurs dans ses
rangs trois tours il ya deux chansons il
ya même qui s'appelle une miss qui
silice héloïse s'immiscer s'est mis à
genoux les autres qui s'appelle je suis
de trop est ce que ceux ci dessous
qu'est-ce que ça traduit des problèmes
avec dutronc julie s'immiscer vraiment
parce que c'est un stationnement qui me
qui me plaisait et puis qui collait bien
à la mélodie
quand enfin à partir du moment où on
fait des textes de chansons forcément
ils traduisent en partie mais en partie
seulement une partie donc votre votre
réalité personnelle parce que vous vivez
personnellement mais bon il ya toujours
comment dire aussi dans cette réalité il
ya toujours une part de l'imaginaire
quelquefois des situations dont je parle
ce sont des situations que j'ai pu
s'imaginer que vécu vraiment mais ça
correspond à des
émotion vraie c'est pas bien avec lui
ouais je touche du bois non c'est que ça
va tu veux que ça dure quoi comment il
va plus qu'il a arrêté de boire il n'a
jamais été aussi séduisant enfin plutôt
lui aussi séduisant qu'au jour où il
était le plus séduisant possible il
fallut que ce pas le moral trop je sais
pas c'est quelqu'un qui parle pas
beaucoup donc c'est difficile un petit
peu de savoir ce qui se passe dans sa
tête je pense que c'est très très
difficile certainement mais il ya des
jours où on sent que c'est difficile
surtout je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
entre autres problèmes à celui de
manquer un peu d'ambition des
difficultés à se mobiliser alors à
s'intéresser lui-même dabo et à partir
du moment où il ya plus stimulant que
l'alcool ça va être encore plus
démotivant une manière générale des
choses c'est bizarre tous les deux parce
que lui quand même donc quand il faisait
des chansons c'était génial
ensuite il a fait du cinéma c'était
encore mieux spielberg a dit qu'il vaut
mieux l'avoir comme acteur piché pendant
l'agression qui dont il n'a pas voulu
apprendre l'anglais puisse la salle est
un peu comme ça c'est parce qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup d'ambitions quand j'ai
quand je les connais
en fait il plaisanté avec ça mais
c'était pas vraiment une plaisanterie il
voulait que j'engage comme jardinier est
souvent j'ai pensé que c'est quelqu'un
qui ont été probants plus heureux s'il
avait une activité qui avait consisté
justement s'occuper de plantes ou
d'animaux puisque je crois que quand il
était plus jeune elle avait pensé être
vétérinaire
non mais c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un qui
est plus près finalement de des plants d
arbres de la nature et des animaux que
déjà toi c'est un peu pareil finalement
je viens tu as toujours du succès est
allé mais comme jacques neau comme dao
qui piétine delattre mais j'admets kitty
la laddh et finalement tu t'arrêtes chez
pas parce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
tous les deux à bruxelles est comme ça
c'est moi je me laisse pas du tout parce
que j'ai un peu de travail et non mais
là tu arrêtes de faire des 10 à faire
autre chose depuis je sais pas on est en
88 ça fait huit ans que j'ai je
travaille comme une folle je suis tout
le temps d'aborder que jamais
disponibilité parce que en même temps ce
fait huit ans que je travaillais pour
une conne station de radio j'ai écrit
2 etc bon d'accord ce qui vous fait ça
non mais de toute façon je crois pas
qu'on puisse mélanger les choses je
pense que jacques de toute façon va
continuer à faire des disques en tout
cas au moins il y en a un qui est prévu
puisque là il est parti en corse pour
composer et puis je pense qu'il a fait
un spectacle aussi alors que moi toute
la partie représentait la partie
représentation pour jacques n'est pas
n'est pas un problème c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a vraiment raté mois pour
moi c'est un problème parce que j'ai
vraiment travaillé
je pense que 20 ans de traque ça suffit
j'arrête plus aujourd'hui bonsoir tu
t'attendais un tel succès pour pour
décalage ton dernier album non après mon
choix parce que tu as fait tes adieux
ça fait 6 a beaucoup de succès oui
partir quand même c'est génial mais non
c'est vrai on nettoie non je me remet
très bien mais c'est bien alors non mais
tu as fait tes adieux et puis on le voit
partout c'est pas désagréable
j'ai pas fait mes adieux jeudi que ce
serait le dernier
ce qu'il faut l'exploiter encore un
petit poème adacore exploit j'écris
couette
alors tu as dit une fois pour moi pour
faire des émissions de télé c'est une
torture c'est terrible le renault lui
s'en fout il n'a pas besoin de faire de
télé pour vendre un million de disques
qui t'as vu ce qui s'est passé il n'a
pas voulu faire de télé il n'a pas vendu
un million de disques
le pauvre tu le plat oui je vais mettre
un cierge pour lui il n'a pas eu ça
s'est très mal passé était au courant
quand m comme quoi il faut être torturés
quand on est artiste ces passionnés
m'intéresse pas très près la carrière de
renault
tu es très capricorne parce que tu as
dit une fois une phrase que je trouve
assez c'est bien tu es la vie est
terrifiante
mais j'aime jamais dit ça cyclisme non
je ne pense avant tout aussi bien mais
j'aime avoir pas mal moi capricornele
rabat joie ouais on t'appelle tu sais
tout ce que j'ai gagné je connais ton
surnom la grande vampire l'adhérent
chance à voile a su faire un majeur
tu as entendu parler des questions des
questions cons
par exemple imagine que tu puisses avoir
quelque chose en plus en plus en plus tu
préfèrerais avoir donné de 7,3 yeux je
crois que jacques préférait que j'ai
deux sexes de ces imagine que tu sois
enceinte de nouveau sur les plaisirs
ah ouais tu fais une échographie et on
te dit voilà votre petit
mais il a deux sexes il a donné où il ya
trois yeux qu'est ce que tu ferais tu te
faire avorter ou tu te garderai parce
que finalement ces cas là c'est comme ça
je garderai pas tu gagnes pas tu fais
comme hitler alors dire que tu les gens
qui sont pas normaux qua non mais je
crois qu'on a choisi le moment on allait
les moyens d'empêcher un être d'avoir
une vie vraiment défavorisés faut
utiliser ses moyens
tu rentres chez toi soir et tu trouves
jacques dutronc au lit avec isabelle
adjani mettant tu te joins à eux ou tu
appelles paris match je me joins à eux
immédiatement voilà tribalisteurs 10e
n'a rien contre les amours saphiques
alors salaires dans ces conditions la
wii avec isabelle adjani ça va oui oui
la condition que jacques soit là ou non
vous séparer avec jacques ça c'est
triste ou séparé le pauvre thomas il se
retrouve tout seul
pourquoi il sera tout seul si on se
sépare et toi aussi enfin pour tout le
monde se souhaita il faut le confier à
quelqu'un ça je hais ce que tu préférais
qu'il soit confié à karen cheryl à
chantal goya ou à dorothée ça s'éteint
c'était récession
oui un dilemme maria santa fe crevé j'ai
bien je ne sais pas du tout je suis déjà
toi sale mère nourricière à qui voudrait
tunisois confié je prends je confie à
chantal goya parce que c'est la seule
que je connaisse des toiles ouais c'est
la seule qui ait des enfants
ouais saviez la télé en plus chantal
goya alors qu'elle s'occuperait du monde
c'est pour ça enfin je crois qu'il
faudrait surtout le monde est invité
omar l'occurrence
ah bon je crois qu'il préférait se passe
et substituts maintenant je vais poser
une question encore plus con si c'est
possible
tu es tu prisonnière et les gens qui te
tiennent comme ça géôliers t'oblige à
faire l'amour avec un animal terrible
s'est jamais pensé non sagem tu vas y
penser pour la première fois ce soir il
était fort tonnage
est-ce que tu préfèrerais un cochon est
un cochon on verra un cochon un chien ou
un âne bien tout en temps tu veux
réfléchir on a le temps là vraiment
c'est très dur il affirmé là c'est quand
même moins bien qu isabelle adjani a bah
oui c'est autre chose j'ai la ville
réserve find go bonne surprise
je sais pas j'aime beaucoup les ânes moi
je trouve ça très bien avant je prendrai
la briche prendre c'est bien c'est les
accords vous avez appelé radio rwanda
alors maintenant si tu devais dîner avec
quelqu'un t'a pas le choix j'ai été
obligé de dîner avec lui pas d'autre
solution
tu préfèrerais dîner avec un sourd muet
ou avec un aveugle bed
gj bien
la vague le mec mais ce que je pourrais
partir ou en dernière question con
françoise hardy oui quelle famille c'est
une question à l'ajax faut anticiper
pour françoise hardy bonsoir une fois
est-ce que c'est pas plus agréable pour
toi de venir à la télévision depuis qu
les plus optimistes
il s'est arrêté sa carrière et que tu
viens ce pour quoi on a toujours la
pression puis appartement c'est un
travail où on sait que ce n'est se faire
pour faire connaître ce travail nous
battre j'ai la pression pour qu'elles
verres promotionnels que vous le disais
tout coûte ou moins qu'avant au moment
de partir tôt de la trappe
tu as dit une fois dans le figaro en 78
je me vois pas en train de chanter à 40
ou 50 ans qu'à cet âge là j'aurais l'air
en avoir alors tu sors un album on va
voir de promotion qui s'appelle vardan
24 ans et equal critères de sélection
pour sony
le critère de sélection malheureusement
il ya des il ya des impératifs tout à
fait extérieur puisque je suis passé
dans pas mal de maisons dix et donc je
ne pouvais pas disposer de tous les
titres
mais disons que le premier critère
c'était forcément des chansons un
premier temps tous les cartes pour la
maison de disques pas tellement pour moi
c'était d'aider les chansons qui
fonctionnait que des gens connaissent un
petit peu comme les tâches personnelles
comme musique sont comme comment tenir
adhérents dans l'eau les choses comme ça
et puis mon critère à moi c'est
évidemment de pouvoir le plaisir pour
moi de participer à une compilation
comme ça c'est de pouvoir
placer quelques titres moins connus et
que j'aime vraiment tu penses quoi de la
version de jimmy somerville de comment
te dire adieu
je suis un peu sur ma faim je pense que
ça aurait pu plus original et ça fait un
peu plus musclé quoi je trouve ça a un
côté auto mode qui était clean
ouais et celle que tu as fait avec lydia
qui sait trop comment parler alors euh
moi je la trouve très très joli très
efficace j'aime bien cette chanson je
regrette simplement que c'est un détail
mais qui compte pour moi j'aime bien
quand une chanson i traditionnelle entre
menti qu'elle étendra j'aime bien coller
que les cordes accentue l'émotion qu'il
ya déjà dans la chanson et je regrette
que dans la chanson dans la version 2
lien on n'entende pas de cordes quoi
c'est tout je reprocherais un petit peu
la linéarité mais sinon je suis un
traître d'avoir trop parlé
c'est tellement différent on se bat
direct madère ça s'est passé comment et
bien jean pierre mader nous a demandé
une chanson à jean-noël shamiyya et au
moins parce que son
décalage avaient fait cinq ou six
chansons et jean noël et sahpresa lien
jean-pierre et on venait de finir ou
chanson qui s'appelait en résumé en
conclusion la dure proposé ça lui a pris
tout de suite voilà voilà simplement on
a été un petit peu surpris quand on a
entendu sa version parce que là mais
c'est pas tout c'est vrai qu'on a
toujours une idée on se fait toujours
une idée des traits pleins d'autres
enfants oui non mais c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est que jean noël qui est
extrêmement doué non seulement en tant
que melody sme pour faire des maquettes
avait fait une maquette et en tous avec
manière il était allé le voir à pitre et
et
la version finale de jean-pierre été
très très très éloignées
de la maquette alors moi je suis senti
un petit peu frustré par rapport à ça
c'est normal samedi qu un son un
traitement et comme j'avais cette
opportunité donnée par ma maison
disent que nous enregistrons 5 titres
pour pour agrémenter un petit peu la
population non je suis plutôt pour
l'enregistrer syncrétique faisons
la chanson de mahler et la chanson
appart ou à celle ci est cher ça s'est
passé comment en ni quoi pourquoi parler
de michel py pour les autres donc on
prend les gens pour qui tout s'est passé
comme moi mais ça s'est passé très
bizarrement parce que oui william
sheller m'a appelé un retour de vacances
en catastrophe pour demander d'écrire
pour lui et
bon après avoir été cinquante fois sa
mélodie subitement l'inspiration a
jailli et j'ai fait un texte que
j'aimais beaucoup je n'aime pas tous mes
textes je trouve pas tous géniaux dans
un format facile à nettoyer pas j'aime
je trouvais qu'il était amusant et qui
collait bien à sa mélodie ça s'appelait
la vraie vie c'est nous et ça commençait
avec nous avec mes pubs mais piolet tout
le tralala mai puis le mont pire et où
mettra dallas vers elle un jour le
sommet l'himalaya je voyais bien au pull
un petit peu et puis j'ai jamais une
nouvelle passe pas qui s'est passé je
jouais à mener jouer à mener le texte
qu'il a il a dîné très très bien et puis
il a fait son propre texte ensuite
et moi comme je tenais beaucoup à ce
texte parce que pour une fois ça ne
parlait pas d'amour et à parler de
spiritualité avec humour avec donc du
coup je lui ai demandé l'autorisation
ensuite pour mon propre sang a déclaré
l'allemand toutes ces chansons je
préfèrerais parler chanter trois mois je
chante je fais tout très difficilement
mon par exemple un chanteur comme julien
clerc puisqu'on parlait de lui il chante
avec beaucoup de facilité
moi je chante avec beaucoup de
difficultés ça ça enlève ses enlève un
petit peu ça enlève même
entièrement le
le président est ce que tu es prête pour
faire la taille ou la calade je connais
pas ça
[Musique]
novak harper c'est facile j'aime autant
la clautre mais je crois que c'est
vraiment vraiment il faut choisir
je croirais mccartney enfin ça c'est une
influence de jacques je crois que
mccartney mba l'autre quand même sabot
sur la longue
en tous les cas il résiste au mieux oui
oui
françoise hardy si je pose la question
comme ça quelle femme est de vous mon
cher jacques chancel jose résultat et je
pèse faire 50 kg comme vous pouvez le
voir des voitures voilà le genre de
femme juste oui je vais répondu ça parce
que je savais pas comment elle peut mais
oui c'est ce qu'il avait dit qu'elle
quel genre de femme et vous j'aurais pu
lui dire je suis une dangereuse aventure
hier quelque chose négative qui dirait
sur toi quelles choses négatives
je dirais
que je vais passer de des choses que je
suis passé
e
coureuses que je suis trop empêtré dans
mes propres problèmes
quelque chose ne fait pas
suffisamment d'efforts pour justement
dans des contrées
je veux que je tourne un petit peu trop
pleurer tant pour la dernière fois alors
là je sais pas mais il n'y a pas très
longtemps qu'on reconnaîtra la feuille
bleue voir la bêtise mais non non je
peux pas répondre à ça parce que tout le
monde est bête et pour sur certains
plans et pas sur d'autres et c'est pas
ni même en général là où moi je peux
être un peu moins bête qu'un autre et
bien je vais beaucoup plus bêtes que
sept autres sur d'autres plans non mais
là je suis en réalité le lieu idéal pour
une autre moi je suis esclave du confort
ça ne sera donc pas l'ascenseur cave
levier aucun cas pas par contre de faire
l'amour incapable et bien
on a tous la question dans toutes celles
que je viens de te poser est elle plus
incité à mentir
c'était un parti la question sur la
victime
[Musique]
et revoici françoise hardy pour un petit
à peine donne avant sachant sonne tout
ce qu'elle aime tout ce qui lui met la
haine
tout y passe et ya de la casse moteur
parce qu'il est le plus dans la vie le
plus dans la vie et c'est difficile à
accepter message
il ya deux choses qui me viennent à
l'esprit d'abord quand j'ai quand il me
semble avoir réussi une chanson ou avoir
fait un texte de chanson j'ai je suis
arrivé tant bien que mal à dire ce que
je voulais dire ça ça me plaît beaucoup
et puis sinon
tout ce qui est mieux dans la vie c'est
d'être avec la personne quand même et
d'échanger des choses a rien eu
qu'est ce qui te gonfle le plus olala
plein de choses
attendre
toutes les corvées qu'il faut faire tous
les jours le genre je ne sais pas évités
avec gt les crottes de chien ex 34
qu'est ce que tu préfères l'ascenseur
qu'est ce que je préfère dans la chanson
commence à en général dans cette chanter
dans la chance dans la chanson ça c'est
l'émotion c'est le fait de pouvoir
exprimer une émotion c'est le fait d'
avec quelque chose qui qui qui vous fait
du mal d'arriver à faire quelque chose
de beau et de jolies et de touchants est
ce que tu te déteste dans la chanson
parce que je déteste dans la chanson et
bien justement je déteste qu'on fasse
des chansons que la tête et pas avec le
coeur
c'est vrai quand tu étais petit prix
grec à l'école parce que ont été
dispensés de cours de chant comment il
sait une chose paraît vrai c'est vrai
parce que j'étais tellement timide et le
le professeur de chant nous faisait
chanter les élèves une à une
et pour éviter ce drame cette
catastrophe donc comme bizarrement les
cours de grec tombait en même temps qui
courent de chevaux pu y jeter la seule
élève d'ailleurs ce qu'est ce qui fait
que je tombais dans la même situation
est ce que tu préfères c'est un bail
parce que je compte faire cesser
son son charisme et sa discrétion
le fait qu'il ait beaucoup de séduction
et qu'il n'en joue jamais que ça à la
limite tu n'en as pas été conscient
d'ailleurs beaucoup
mini souvent qui enfin qu'il en est rien
qu'il en ai jamais rien à [__] d'avoir
7 7 cette séduction vraiment enfin bon
disons que ça jamais c'est plein de
chance et plein de choses
enfin à vrai dire j'ai presque mûrs
profite ce que tu aimes pas chez lui
alors je vais appliquer cette base ouais
j'aime beaucoup changé ces derniers
temps r je serais étonné beaucoup plus
facilement à l'esprit ici si on avait
fait cette interview il ya quelques
semaines
ah oui c'est incroyable
on fait peut-être peut-être peut-être
qu'il a il n'éprouve jamais le besoin
vraiment de dire d'exprimer
et tout c'est un petit peu dommage parce
qu'au bout d'un certain temps finalement
on en vient à vivre chacun dans son coin
là puisse parler et se croisent j'avais
une bonne chance à faire le meilleur
chanteur pour toi de tous les temps ou
la meilleure chanteuse
j'ai un faible pour david bowie parce
que encore je connaisse pas comme
certains fans toutes ses chansons de la
jusqu'à zen mes jetons c'est un artiste
complet
il ya très très peu d'artistes dont on
puisse dire ça de plus une niche chez
fayard
il ya plein de gens que je vois de temps
en temps des invectives je vous dis
qu'est ce que c'est que ça paie je
m'aperçois que ça je m'aperçois lavande
s'était classé dans le top 5 ans je ne
me souviens pas des noirs et 10 ans
comme ce sont des gens que je ne connais
pas et comme malgré tout offert une
chose je voudrais encore en disant ah
non risquer de les blesser
geneviève forest truman
ok ok ah bah voilà j'ai trouvé un nom
j'ai trouvé un autre demis roussos
je pense qu'il a la 3ci découvert deux
fois c'est un fait que j'aimerais ça
mais non j'aime pas ses chansons contes
des chansons vraiment beaucoup trouvent
basique l'allemand et les musiciens et
par qui tu préfères je connais mal je
connais mal la musique je suis tout à
fait un coude
disons que j'ai un faible pour tant pis
pour le ridicule mais j'adore cela
j'adore le concert numéro 2 de
rachmaninov c'est bien qu'est-ce que tu
détestes je voulais en venir c'est pas
que je déteste ça me laisse complètement
froid d'un naturel moi je sais qui c'est
qu'il est alors c'est c'est
mozart et j'ai et j'ai l'occasion de 10
de la seule posture non justement parce
que j'en ai parfois peut-être lui n'en
sera pas le dire ça dans une émission
mais j'en ai parlé avec serge gainsbourg
et j'ai vu dans son regard une lueur
d'intérêt pour moi mais le jour je
design manie si m
moi non plus je n'aime pas chez les
acteurs ceux qui préfèrent acheter
oui oui oui j'aime j'aime bien me
kerrous que
d'abord j'ai toujours bien ses doigts
alors qu'elle me coeur oui c'est moi la
simple spectatrice gamme est décédé avec
qui il a effectué des tests comme acteur
je trouve que depardieu par exemple est
un acteur très inégale je trouve que moi
enfin bon peut-être que tous les acteurs
sont inégaux que le donnent le meilleur
d'eux mêmes quand effectivement ils sont
bien mais bien dirigés je trouve que
depardieu pour elle très inégale alors
maintenant ce que tu préfères dans le
sexe la demande pendant et après
fectivement mais je viens de dire ah bon
avant pendant et après ça c'est ce que
tu préfères que tu détestes d'orsay je
ne sais pas par tout le monde aime
quelqu'un tout eh bien voilà c'est quand
on aime pour moi c'est inimaginable
je sais qu'au contraire c'est très bien
pour nous
jours mais disons que tout ce qu'on fait
dans ce domaine là eux
pour moi serait impossible effectivement
très
répugnant si je n'écris rien du tout pas
d'amour pour la personne derrière tu
détestes dans le sexe on peut en rester
là
est ce que tu préfères en toi que je
préfère en moi par exemple je n'aurais
pas aimé être
être une femme fort enfin j'aurais quand
même préféré est un peu plus ronde
sanitaire ce que tu as en toi que je
préfère au bon ton intelligent et
brillant de tous news qu'est ce que tu
aimes pas chez moi j'aime pas chez toi
c'est que c'était encore perpétuelle de
maquillage
bon je te faire une interview coq à
l'âne est ce que tu préfères être un coq
ou bien un âne je préfère encore être ce
que je suis bien que je sois pas
terrible est ce que tu as déjà pensé au
suicide
oui enfin c'est à dire j'ai l'impression
que ma vie est un lent suicide est ce
que tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour
réussir
non je crois pas du tout je crois que
quand quelqu'un un vrai talent il
réussit forcément qu'est ce que tu veux
de plus sexy en toi eh bien j'aimerais
beaucoup de savoir c'est tu pourrais me
le dire ça me rendrait faire vivre et de
moins sexy tout il ya l'embarras du
choix
je pense où sont mes ongles de pieds
parce que j'ai fait tomber une grosse
valise une fois et puis maintenant il
pousse pas très bien à quoi je reconnais
tu infailliblement la passion les sens
chez moi ou chez quelqu'un de chez toi
c'est ça se reconnaît au fait que
subitement on peut plus passer d'une
présence et la passion qui s'éteint
qu'on peut s'en passer kita découverte
professionnellement je la personne qui
m'a qui m'a signé mon premier contrat
c'est jacques bolson qui reste est un
ami et sexe ul mans sexuellement
la première personne qui est vraiment
compté pour moi c'est jean marie périer
c'est pas un secret est-ce que tu
m'aimes mais j'aime surtout d'autres
gens certaines personnes d'une manière
de ne pas penser à ces mais où est passé
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue pour la dernière de double jeu
on a beaucoup de chance parce que tu ne
fais plus de tutelle montée n'est plus
tellement de promotion mais là en fait
maintenant tu l'as fait pourtant
pourtant poulain pour alain les bras non
pas seulement comme pas seulement comme
dans tous les cas on est très content de
t'avoir alors quand tu as débuté tu
aurais aimé rencontrer françoise hardy
non pourquoi
pour décrire des belles cuvées toi sur
son label non je ne sais pas comment
répondre à ça non mais je pense ça c'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses
en tous les cas pour pour pour le cas là
dont on parle je pense que c'est une
chance pour moi d'avoir rencontré
d'avoir eu cette opportunité de
rencontrer quelqu'un de plus jeune et de
travailler pour quelqu'un de plus jeune
et avec lui c'est surtout avec lui
dans la mesure où ça ou ça m'oblige à
renouveler un petit peu ma façon
d'écrire à traiter dans les textes que
j'ai fait donc fait que j'essayais de
faire à traiter d'autres thèmes que des
thèmes
dont je parle le plus facilement à
l'époque où tu avais la jambe un petit
peu plus jeune que les bras nous
aujourd'hui tu habitais trinité c'est
vrai que j'habitais à deux pâtés de
maison de dutronc aidé à l'idée qu'ils
n'avaient jamais rencontré
si johnny j'avais j'avais rencontré en
fin de loin je l'avais vu passer dans
une voiture ils habitaient oui
j'habitais à deux rues de lui il était
rue de la tour des dames et moi
j'habitais rue d'aumale et on allait
chez le même crémiers j'ai su ça après
que j'aie jamais rencontré chez le
prévenu de jacques martin et il
commençait tout juste à être connu et je
l' ai vu passer une fois vous en voiture
j'étais tout à fait en théorie oui pas
non pas vraiment à cette époque là ça a
été je les apprécie je n'apprécie pas
ces disques des débuts je trouvais que
c'était des disques très bâclée et
et j'ai apprécié surtout quand j'ai vu
sur scène comme d'ailleurs la plupart
des gens ta mère était être comptable à
mi temps et elle s'est fait faire deux
enfants par un homme n'était pas
amoureux simplement pour se sortir de
son milieu
c'est vrai ça ouais c'est vrai ça je
sais pas si c'était pour se sortir de
son milieu consciemment je pense que tu
es plus inconscients comme je pense
qu'elle était très flatté de voir
qu'elles provoquaient des sentiments
très forts chez chez quelqu'un qui était
d'un milieu très différent du sien et
ils ont rompu en fait ton père et ta
mère ils ont été de se voir quand il y
avait trois ans quand j'ai tu voyais et
on perd trois fois par an à peu près non
ouais quelque chose comme ça et il
paraît que tu avais pas le droit quand
tu lui écrivait de mettre ton nom sur
les leds parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas
que les gens avec qui il s'agit
oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai parce que
mon père avait sa vie de son côté
c'était
une relation la relation à ma mère était
quand même clandestine et donc les
et ma soeur et moi nous étions des
enfants
clandestine j'ai pas d'autres et on perd
en fête a commencé à se vanter d'être
ton père quand il est devenu célèbre
c'est un fait que c'est un fait que j'ai
su que qui ne se cachait plus d'être
d'être mon père le jour le jour j'étais
un petit peu connu et un jour tu as
appris que ton père était homosexuel
ça marche ça m'a rien fait particulier
parce que je trouve que chacun c'est ça
ses penchants à sa façon d'être
moi je ça m'a récemment je trouvais ça
plutôt amusé en fait ça me fait rire
quand il était petit et pas trop
d'argent avait une jupe et pis tu es tu
à user les semelles de ses chaussures
jusqu'à la corde
tu as tu regardes quête souvient de
cette époque ce n'est pas une période
dont j'aime me souvenir à part que j'ai
quand même eu la chance d'avoir une
maman qui m'aimait beaucoup qui aimait
beaucoup ses enfants et donc ça c'est
quand même moins aux privilèges par
contre ta grand mère tu l'aimés pas
beaucoup j'avais une grand-mère très
particulière et on dirait aujourd'hui
qu'elle était névrosé
extrêmement important je sais pas elle
était plutôt du genre hystéro alors elle
par contre n'avait pas beaucoup d'amour
et hans à elle été très
nuisible pour son entourage elle te
parler des hommes elle te disais que
c'est tous des [__] préoccupés par la
chose
oui c'était d'autrui à peu près parce
que c' est pas tout à fait ces mots là
mais c'était d'autant plus surprenante
qu'elle était mariée à un homme donc mon
grand père qui était le contraire de ça
tu es quelqu'un de tout à fait je pense
qu'elle a aimés au problème les spots et
là comme tout les hystériques n'était
pas très gentil avec toi je te disais
que c'était pas belle déjà offert un
gros ventre quand on voit maintenant
parce qu'elle me faisait manger des
lentilles des flageolets leur salle de
bain comme ça pour te dire tu avais un
grand mais c'est vrai qu'avec quelque
chose d'assez médecin chez ma grand mère
elle tête arrive à de complexes et
finalement à mais complètement je sais
pas il paraît que tu le faisais puis
enlever ton manteau que tu voulais
jamais de mettre en maillot
les gammes arriver à tout le monde en
quoi je pense que beaucoup des problèmes
que j'ai pu avoir et dont j'ai forcément
encore les séquelles assez importantes
viennent de du déséquilibre très très
beau fort de madame enterré dans une
école catho privé oui je fais la bruyère
pour emmerder parce que bon tu étais pas
si tu quand même des egos assez riche
c'est fric et à ça c'était pas que
j'étais un homme et redit à cause de ça
c'était que je me sentais déplacer en
fait c'est vrai que j'ai eu une enfance
où finalement je me suis sentie toujours
un peu déplacé quand les mouvements à
partir du moment où on devait plus ou
moins se cacher par rapport à mon père
et ses partisans ont se trouvait dans
une école où les autres enfants avaient
une situation tout à fait normale et et
ma soeur et moi non
où en plus ses autres enfants avaient
des parents un petit peu plus aisée que
ma mère ne l'était donc il y avait des
décalages comme ça qui faisait que enfin
moi j'ai prouvé assez facilement un
sentiment de honte de on2
quand tu passes ta première audition
chez pathé marconi c'est la catastrophe
parce qu'on te dis que ça ressemble trop
à marie-josée neuville oui non mais pour
moi ça n'était pas une catastrophe parce
que j'ai tellement persuadé que j'allais
dire et au bout de 30 secondes est en
fait ils m'ont gardé au moins un quart
d'heure alors après tu es allé chez
vogue alors là par contre ça a marché et
jacques bolson qui était signée a tout
de suite mais en fait assez rapidement
oui alors là tu as fait tous les garçons
et les filles
oui enfin c'est l'achat de cette chanson
pour laquelle il est engagé qui était
sur le disent d'ailleurs c'était c'était
une autre banque s'approcher lit c'était
comme un gène syngap1 tu fais ces
paroles de gilles et jean même temps
cela va lui même quand tu ne fais rien
ça me plaît je me souviens alors pour
évoquer ces années là je vais te faire
une interview bouzou on va prendre un
certain nombre de gens de l'époque et tu
vas me dire ce que tu en penses comment
tu les as connu ce qui s'est passé avec
qui on va commencer face touch
johnny hallyday il est persuadé que
pendant qu'il faisait son service
militaire je lui écrivais tout je lui
écrivais tous les jours pour
l'encourager toujours ce que je n'ai
absolument jamais fait une seule fois
qu'il me voit et on serait pas soit on
doit tous les dix ans à chaque fois il
me rappelle ce truc là que j'ai envoyé
une carte postale je ne sais pas et
alors il a transformé sa sylvie vartan
tu la connais comment j'avais participé
à musicorama à l'olympia et à l'époque
elle avait un très très bon gros chagrin
d'amour et ceux qui annonça je dirais
pas
et j'avais été très bouleversée par par
son chagrin parce que c'est vraiment
c'était plus que des larmes quand
c'était presque des hurlements elle
voulait presque se suicider si j'avais
été bouleversé par sa donc ça c'est mon
premier souvenir extrêmement marquant de
sid lee qui naturellement ne l'a rendu
immédiatement à ce moment sympathique
c'est là que tu as défend toujours chez
la gent marqué dans toutes les
interviews tu dit du bien d'elle tu les
aimes tu le défends
de toute manière je me sens quand même
un petit peu solidaires de sylvie et
sheila dans l'avion finalement on a
débuté ensemble on a connu un petit peu
la même aventure donc sacré malgré soi
des liens et c'est vrai que ce que
j'apprécie c'est le fait que
quel est qu'elle ait voulu évoluer et
qu'elle ait su évoluer en même temps si
public n'a pas suivi vraiment en tant qu
il aurait dû c'est une autre affaire
mais j'ai beaucoup apprécié ça chez elle
et puis en même temps ce que j'aime chez
elle bon que sylvie a aussi c'est
qu'elle a une pêche et un dynamisme
incroyable est que quoi qu'il arrive
même dans les moments vraiment
difficiles elle et elle reste positive
alors l'époque tab un succès fou il ya
une chanson qui s'appelait all over the
world bizarrement et que j'ai donc qui
était une chanson en fait que j'avais
fait paroles et musique et que j'ai
enregistré en anglais et qui bizarrement
est un succès dans son pays
en gros sacs sont enfin donc l'australie
nouvelle zélande afrique du sud au qatar
en contre et mick jagger
alors il a dit que tu étais son idéal
féminin mais si jamais passé il n'y a
pas il me l'a pas dit j'ai lu ça dans un
terrain oui j'ai jamais rien eu d'autre
entre vos noms et la rencontre brian
jones à l'époque oui et tu dis je ne
réalisais pas à l'époque ils étaient
tous drogués scénique des français c'est
vrai que j'ai mis mes des années avant
de comprendre ce que c'était que d'être
calme dans quel état je les trouvais
bizarre alors oui oui effectivement
parce que à cette époque là dans les
années 60 il y avait des boîtes à la
mode en angleterre c'est curieux parce
que ça change et on revenait au bout de
trois mois à londres et c'était plus la
même voix a donc été à la mode et dans
ses boîtes à la mode on voyait
les beatles on est tous les groupes les
plus saines donc les stones mick jagger
les animaux etc
effectivement je trouvais qu'ils étaient
très très étrange que je combattrai il y
avait c'était difficile d'avoir les
temps n'ont jamais proposé à l'époque
c'est un peu égoïste quand même car tous
les cas c'est toi que je c'est vrai que
j'ai vu assez souvent
ryan jones il venait me voir dans
à l'hôtel où j'étais et puis moi même je
me rappelle chalet une fois chez lui et
jamais ou alors peut-être peut-être
qu'il m'a proposé une cigarette mais je
n'ai pas du tout réalisé que c'était la
joie c'est pour ça que ça mais comme je
ne fumais pas donc c'est l'époque de la
libération sexuelle sur la croquer une
de coadout de cette époque de libération
sexuelle de la fin des 70 alors je sais
pas moi j'ai pas eue
je sais pas comment dire t'es pas dans
ce coup là e
non mais je veux dire pour pour pour
pour se libérer il faut faut déjà au
départ avoir des problèmes points et moi
j'ai eu la chance que tout se passe très
bien tout de suite donc j'avais pas je
me verrais puisque j'étais pas prêt à
lui faire l'amour à plusieurs vivre nu
tout ça tu as ça c'est pas forcément une
libération non mais à l'époque ça
apparaissait comme une libération
oui je sais pas peut-être la question
c'est est-ce que tu l'as fait ou pas
après ces années d'or que furent les
années 60
tu entames tuto grande carrière l'époque
soit fin des 60 début des 70's ensuite
il entame sa deuxième carrière
est il apte à changer tu as dit j'ai
appris à dire non et il m'a fallu dix
ans pour apprendre à dire non
c'était si dur que ça non moi quand je
quand j'ai débuté j'étais inconscient de
plein plein plein de choses et on est
encore plus de
de moi-même et donc c'est petit à petit
qu'on apprend à connaître ses limites et
à savoir qu'il vaut mieux refuser tel
type de choses parce que c'est pas pour
soi parce qu'on n'a pas la carrure il
faut pour ça je suis pas une réputation
dans le métier en fait il s'est quand
même temps tu sais comment t'appelles
non non je sais pas non mais dimanche en
même temps tu râles par exemple contre
les télés étudie on arrive à la télé on
attend d eux on est dans des loges
infâme
ensuite on est mal éclairé je touche 10
h et qui sont pas supérieures à ce que
je touchais à mes débuts ça c'est vrai
que j'ai dit ça souvent voilà trente ans
j'ai touché mieux mal chaque fois que je
passe à la télé web est alors alors
qu'en principe bon le cours de la vie
avait augmenté les salaires de toutes
les autres professions aussi oui oui oui
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai que je trouve
que
oui rien rien n'est jamais assez bien
c'est la deuxième époque françoise hardy
un peu plus directif dans sa carrière
des disques magnifique je pars tu aimes
pas qu'on te fasse des compliments et tu
sais j'ai eu quelques beaux disques la
fois la musique sous le thème pas la
chanson mais j'étais très bon mais non
ce n'est pas un peut pas dire que c'est
très beau c'est une chanson humoristique
chansons humoristiques n'est pas belle
facture allégée mais j'aime qu'on soit
prêt si on a commencé à t'occuper de ton
grand dada l'astrologie c'est pas que
j'ai commencé à m'occuper de mon grand
dada c'est qu'à partir du moment où j'ai
plus de temps pour moi quand j'ai arrêté
de faire de la scène parce que
malheureusement pour les quelques
personnes qui sont venues me voir j'ai
fait de la scène pendant un certain
temps et donc j'ai donc ayant du temps
devant moi je ne savais pas comment
l'employé et comme j'ai un petit peu
enfin je suis un petit peu une étudiante
attardé donc donc j'avais envie de
suivre des cours de quelque chose et
puis j'ai finalement j'ai atterri dans
des cours d'astrologie et ça c'est plus
ou moins su évidemment alors donc très
vite j'ai eu des propositions de travail
dans ce domaine là c'est comme ça que
les choses se sont développées j'ai pas
tout demander une consultation mais
comment ça va pour le capricorne
ça dépend si on est début a lieu chaque
apparition en plus donc on va s'arrêter
tout de suite avant de laurent baffie
était allé voir les gens dans la rue
pour leur parler de françoise hardy et
l'astrologie à tout à fait tu m'entends
mouchoirs je serre les dents voilà
laurent baffie
[Musique]
bonjour est ce que vous aimez françoise
hardy sur le plateau de double jeu ah
j'ai un cap à cette émission
quoi qu'il en soit et sur le plateau
elle ne chante plus après c'est dommage
parce que j'aimais bien ces champs sont
censés consacrer exclusivement à la
sueur logis est ce que vous voulez avoir
une chance à lui dis plus rien parce que
son confrère celle à arrêter donc la
single exemple un petit haut risque pour
demain oui j'ose hardy a fait ses
propres l'astrologie elle dit pas de
métro pour demain réseau via spécifiques
et elle voit une catastrophe pour vous
si vous prenez le métro de moscou un
accident c'est pas gai bagués du tout
scorpion ascendant scorpion comme alain
delon me dit elle tiens je ne savais pas
ok oui allez vous dit que la conjoncture
est très noir pour demain du pommeau de
douche madame pardon renvoyer une
minerve conseil demain d'aller voir
votre toubib qui arrivait une erreur de
diagnostic qui pourrait entraîner des
séquelles graves pour demain ah bon elle
me dit qu'en ce moment il y avait le
mercure dont l'uranus et c'est chaud
pour vous en ce moment là en amour yann
laphin eyquem le calme plat ouais vous
aimeriez ont souvent des personnes
absolument pas même le confirme c'est
pas demain que j'avais trouvé la preuve
de votre vie
elle vous dit que vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri des fautes de goût fringues et
madame et me demande si vous vous
habillez parfois sous l'emprise de la
drogue
non pas du tout elle me dit qu'il est un
sacré blaireau un bon vous traite 1 1
c'est vrai qu'hier l'euro est un sacré
que tard également
ah bon vous aimait beaucoup les femmes
bah oui pourquoi pas et vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'une honnêteté exemplaire avec
m ah bon vous avez des aventures en ce
moment le rendre auprès spécialement pas
spécialement
elle comprend vous pouvez pas parler
mais elle me dit vous dire que
ça va aller en s'arrangeant pour ce que
vous savez yabon faisait des petits
poèmes de parfois de gens et vous avez
des petits problèmes gastriques pas du
tout bon foulée un peu du du boulot moi
je sais pas je vois pas des docteurs
depuis 30 ans évitez le karaté la moto
la moto oui éviter la moto mouchet oui
oui oui ça passe de deltaplane vous ne
me voulaient régler je peux précédé
chanteront pour l'horoscope le nom de
bar débat sans payer puisqu'ils sont
francs basse et françoise hardy comment
vous portez sont payés alors quand vous
l'avez pas demandé est ce que c'est moi
vous permettez à bien vous permettez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
exactement ça que tu fais alors tu as
déclaré au matin de paris
genest du matin de paris pendant les six
premiers mois avec dutronc c'était
formidable
et puis du jour au lendemain tout a
changé et qui m'a toujours et on pouvait
plus se voir que de jour sur 3 ou un
jour sur deux tu t'en souviens d'avoir
dit ça
je l'étais je me souviens pas du tout de
l'avoir dit mais j'essaie possible que
je les dis parce qu'effectivement du
jour au lendemain on ne s'est plus vu
qu'une fois par semaine tous les quinze
jours quelque chose comme ça et
maintenant voyez tous les combien
maintenant c'est une deux fois par
semaine ça va moins ça va
et pourquoi ça parce que tu crois que
les hommes changent quand ils se savent
mais non mais là c'est tout simplement
parce qu'ils préparent indices dont nous
une maison à la campagne pour pouvoir
travailler tranquille et c'est la seule
raison là où bien sûr bon toi tu étais
très très amoureuse de lui il te traiter
midinettes il te trouvais trop amoureuse
rasoli très détaché très cynique on sait
pas c'est pas facile tour est tombée
amoureuse qui me traitait de midinette
c'est parce que j'ai toujours aimé des
chansons sentimentales
tu t'es perdu le bilan de votre relation
aujourd'hui parce que tu as dis tu veux
moi tu veux que je le fasse
oui massif oui façon ce n'est pas mieux
moi ce travail
ben oui oui vas-y tu dis si je devais
faire le bilan de notre relation est
prête
gt gt les plus souvent malheureuses
qu'heureuse as tu l'as cherché
oui mais je pense que ce soit toi qui te
disent ouais moi comme j'ai pas à dire
ça surtout ici
quoi ici on est tous les deux oui non
mais c'est vrai mais je juge que oui
mais je crois que de toute manière dans
toute relation forte
les moments de bonheur sont plus sont
plus rares que le reste c'est la vie
c'est comme ça je crois que le bonheur
est plus rare que le rêve c'est pour ça
qu'on court après est ce que tu crois
pas que finalement ces moments de
malheur ces moments plus malheureux que
les autres 10 ans parce que tu crois pas
c'est ça qui fait ton ton talent bon je
me suis souvent posé la question qu'est
ce que j'aurais préféré ce que j'aurais
préféré avoir une vie un tout petit peu
plus tranquille un tout petit peu plus
sereine n'aurais pas écrit plus simple
dans mes attirances donc rencontrer des
gens plus simples et plus faciles à
vivre plus facile plus facile à aimer il
pas faire de chansons je ne sais pas je
peux pas m'attendre à ça j'en sais rien
au début vous avez vécu longtemps chacun
chez soi
oui un et je pense d'ailleurs maintenant
que c'est la meilleure c'est la
meilleure solution
comme michel morange gérard oury oui ce
temps le cepd si on racontait toujours
ça que michel morvan et gérard où il
vivait séparé que c'est très bien non
mais ça malheureusement c'est un fait
que la promiscuité le quotidien ça et
mousse beaucoup les choses comme est
justement jacques est quelqu un qui sait
tout à fait se rendre absents 20 quand
il est là quoi la firme problèmes du
quotidien se repose un petit peu moins
et toi ça te rappelle pas un peu ta
propre en france finalement ça cette
espèce de séparation c'est pas quelque
chose que tu recherches tu me fait une
psychanalyse est une consultation assez
logique
vous avez quand même décidé de vivre
ensemble finalement c'était sans doute
après la naissance de votre fils thomas
non ouais pour lui pour te mois oui oui
bien sûr bien sûr avant tout avant tout
ouais mais pour moi aussi enfin pour
tous la désole un peu popote quand même
non j'ai toujours été pas fait d'études
j'ai des fédés boeuf gros sel
aussi cette boule hard c'est la personne
fatigue ça mettront côté me fais rien je
sais pas j'ai mais c'est pas un mec
comme ça qui est une pépite est une star
et où il la retrouve en train de faire
des boeufs gros sel et tout à vapeur ça
non c'est pas mauvais ça me rappelle que
ça me rappelle emmanuel berl dit
théodore le mari de mme mireille
absolument à qui bon que je voyais assez
souvent je n'ai jamais passé quelques
heures avec lille après midi combien il
n'était pas là il me mettait toujours en
gare me disait faites très attention
jacques dutronc et plus enfin est tombé
amoureux est tombé amoureux d'une star
et face d'une femme de ménage du beurre
derrière ça va eh bien ils avaient à la
photo et raison parce que c'est en fait
moi qui me suis lassé d'être une femme
de ménage
j'en ai marre maintenant j'ai fini c'est
fini alors tu fais du fin du surgelé
quand elle est bien réelle et non alors
est ce que comme disait pialat au sujet
d'un autre film que van gogh
tu crois que vous avez dit lire ensemble
je l'espère parce que j'étais dieu
présent quand écoute un disque il écoute
des milliers de fois je veux dire non
mais lui ça les nerfs du tronc de ce
genre de trucs dedans tu crois pas à
tuer mme anissa veut le rendre fou pipi
les siennes ils doivent se rendre folle
aussi non pas des personnalités très
fortes comme ça ça va être dur non mais
non à cause de ce que je te dis parce
que bon il est
il est pas tout le temps là et puis même
quand il est là il est extrême c'est
quelqu'un de très discret et moi aussi
sauf effectivement quand je me suis
entiché d'une chanson là je suis pas
discrète du tout parce que je la mets
très fort et est très souvent
j'avoue que ça c'est mon plus gros
défaut il te sera beaucoup pardonné
quand tu le vois faire l'amour au cinéma
avec une fille ça te fait quoi
j'aime pas ah bon l'écouté de toute
manière je n'aime pas le voir au cinéma
déjà enfin l'avenir en dehors en dehors
de ces situations particulières
je ne gêne pas le voir au cinéma doit
avoir les quand ça se fait pas sa
maîtresse à me gêne beaucoup j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'ils jouent très
très mal qui jalousent comme fille la
jalousie c'est plus quelque chose qu'on
éprouve soit comme savons par exemple si
je sais qui va tourner avec telle
actrice que je trouve moi absolument
sublime
ça va me ça va me tourmenter je dirais
je sais que j'ai eu un été gâchée par
exemple par par serge gainsbourg qui
m'avait téléphoné
pour me demander de parler à jacques
d'un projet de film qui l'avait lui
serge et dans les dents pour lequel il
souhaitait comme acteur jacques et
charlotte rampling à l'époque charlotte
rampling pour moi c'était vraiment la
femme idéale dans toute sa splendeur
afin de fatal et vraiment je me suis dit
s'ils tournent avec alors la gelée dans
le dos elle est absolument irrésistible
et comme je le trouvais lui plus
irrésistible que le mari de charlotte
rampling que je trouve pas mal non j'ai
précisé que je trouve très bien aussi
mais très bon et j'ai vraiment ça m'a
gâché mon thé voilà comment ma jalousie
peut se peut se vivre je ne sais pas
mais je ne manifeste pas ne se passe
rien fait alors la maison vous avez
chacun votre zone un peu c'est vrai que
quand vous avez des choses importantes à
vous dire vous écrivez il fait des
petits mots des fois oui moi j'ai fait
ça pendant très longtemps parce que
c'est quelqu'un qu'il est difficile de
parler donc
comme seul recours de lui écrire des
lettres auxquelles d'ailleurs il me
répondait que tu voudrais peu avant mais
répondait pas rendement très peu traité
il est dur c'est pas qu'il soit dur
c'est que c'est je pense maintenant je
crois que je peux dire ça je pense qu'il
a effectivement un problème de
communication
et voilà dis moi tu vas pas le voir dans
sa chambre en plus parce que ça pue le
cigare comme je suis pas si vous faites
un cv qui viennent de bordeaux retient
que tu as dit je ne rentre jamais dans
sa chambre ça pulse igas était fait et
que quelquefois ça m'est arrivé de balai
dans sa chambre pour lui dire pour les
virements ou évidemment ils pas tous
dans sa chambre quand il y est depuis
depuis un certain nombre d'heures et que
et qu'il a en chine des cigares /
cigarillos non c'est une tabagie
infernal quoi c'est insupportable
ressort immédiatement qu'en fait le
conseil vrai qu'il fait beau il fait
beaucoup pour décourager la proche s'est
toujours fait mais pas seulement avec
nous avec toi ça va pas marcher souffle
à marcher quand même évidemment ce que
tu conseille aux gens pour que ça marche
dans un couple c'est d'avoir tout en
double les chambres les toilettes les
toilettes ses traders
politiquement tu fais mal voir par la
classe médiatique le jour où tu as dit
le racisme anti français existe aussi tu
a regretté ce fichage après j'ai pas dit
ça j'ai simplement dit dans une espèce
de conversation à bâtons rompus qui
était pas du tout destiné à être publié
ad
liste avec qui j'avais passé une journée
au lendemain des élections j'ai site
j'ai parlé du brio de la répartie de
quelqu'un dont on n'a absolument pas le
droit de dire le nom sinon immédiatement
n'est considérée comme sympathisante bon
alors j'ose à peine le dire maintenant
parce que je ne suis pas sympathisante
mais je trouve qu'à l'époque j'ai cité
enfin j'ai parlé du brio de ses
réparties et j'avais cité c'est très
parti de jean marie le pen quoi mais
c'est tout alors depuis se trouve que
j'ai découvert petit à petit toujours en
bonne mr magoo qui a des gens qui
pensent que je suis le pénis que je suis
sympathisant cette serre à je ne sais
pas s'ils sont des gens du front
national qui ont essayé de récupérer
quelque chose par rapport à moi aussi
sont d'autres je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt des les gens qui tuent et très
mal ou pas ce que tu en avais pas appris
à parler le showbiz c'est qu'il ya des
choses qui se disaient qu'ils disent pas
dans ceux les gens fin en soi ah oui bah
oui bah voila voila tu penses les
dictatures du consensus en france
aujourd'hui
moi je ne veux plus répondre à des
questions comme ça qu'ils sont qui sont
un petit peu qui t'amène sur des
terrains glissants parce
qu'effectivement il ya tout peut être
mal interprété ton moi moi même étonné
que je trimballe une casserole que je
trouve absurde
donc je ne veux plus parler de certaines
choses tu as 10 mai 68 mais passer au
dessus de la tête tu faisais quoi 68
et bien justement j'étais très jamais eu
envie de te révolter contre les flics
d'aller casser des crs
maintenant mes cheveux je sais pas c'est
à dire que ce rôle à la commande comme
en réponse comment ne pas dire de
de bêtises en répondant à ça moi je
n'aime pas les généralités je trouve
qu'on peut pas détester un corps de
métier en bloc et je trouve que bon il
ya des gens qui disent je déteste les
flics je hais les flics et c'est moi
simplement je dis que de temps en temps
je suis bien content qu'il soit là que
par exemple dans les périodes
d'attentats de terrorisme et serra
j'étais bien contente qu'ils en aient et
puis je pense que dans ce corps de
métier là comme dans tout corps de
métier il y aller il ya les bons et les
moins bons enfants nés des gens bien ils
ne vont pas bien on va regarder une
histoire de flics pour en finir laurent
baffie l'affût
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'histoire à double jeu c'est de la
merde non plus j'ai fixé l'heure à
comprendre il ya des astuces des jeunes
moïse était un peu largué quand même
sans henry oui je dois avouer quand même
fait peur en temps plein un petit
bonhomme tu avais bien les missions à
rester pas mal ces défis des non pas
fidèle mais bon j'aurais le temps en
temps sans samedi soir avec ça tu as pas
le choix voilà
[__] il est collector ton pin's
[__] je te les champions ont été les
changements alléchant v3 [__] alors
non mais la terra toi-même disent même
10 voire 12 12
c'est mon service tempez ce sera un
petit rythme un des bijoux nom complet
j'ai rien compris
soit les papiers oui france des procès
sur les paliers c'est le pv non mais on
va tenter au nom était dès maintenant
non mais tu veux maintenant faites votre
boulot jusqu'au bout alors c'est
scandaleux je vous annulez toutes les
preuves c'est scandaleux on va voir
un portait de bague non
c'est dans le rendez compte si à chaque
fois qu'on a un concert mal à les étaler
les prunes c'est ce qu'on a le temps son
embauche au second point le plus bas oui
je veux évidemment ça veut peut-être
qu'il va même pas la tire et ses
tatouages
je n'aime pas la tire et la ctu de
raconter des petites questions est ce
que t bones ou l'homme vous faites ça
madame vous avez pas envie d'avoir un
métier honnête il est honnête mon métier
autant susciter minutes et 1
c'est bien vous m'offrez une gas
activité pendant dans ces conditions je
pense qu'une petite fellation est hors
de question
pas le droit non plus non si c'est pour
un porno qui part au danemark tout de
suite eu ce soir on l'envoie de suite
ainsi au petit bisou non ça va quand
même battu par l'inspection mettez vous
mettez vous bien en ligne jean-benoît
meute en ligne mon petit bonhomme moto
en ligne peu près par l'inspection vous
bien vos moyens un peu tendu comme moins
de bruit bien robert ya un repère
superbe revers toinon bien oui ça paraît
trop de bruit à la barbe
on l'a dit n'avoir pas de barbe
christophe bien en ligne c'est bien
avocat manor auguste raux
[Applaudissements]
et
dis moi on arrive au but quand l'obus
ciel je croyais qu'on l'avait dépassé
déjà ma et qui touche au but qu'ils
trouvent sexy à part d'être en saas et
alizée 187 à bercy tu as dit qu'il était
jubilatoire mais j'ai jamais dit ça
c'est un terme que un jubilatoire son
spectacle oui ou non à 8 min son
spectacle à venir celui de la 3g jubilé
pendant tout le spectacle c'était
c'était c'était la joie je vis là
thouarcé ça c'est beau sexy bon d'accord
elvis presley à il a eu une époque où je
dois retrouver tout à fait comme ça où
je suis je suis même pas les lois on est
allé le voir à l'époque où il a repris
la scène il était vraiment très très
bien cette époque là après heureusement
ça a dégénéré
l'implant pas mal tu allais ta [__] tu
as pu le toucher l'approché basselet non
non ce qui me tue trouver sexy presley
c'était pâques oui à une époque précise
que si oui oui j'ai toujours trouvé
comme ça et maintenant
maintenant encore j'ai vu il n'ya pas
longtemps
à son dernier concert à l'olympia j'ai
trouvé qu'il était toujours aussi bas
mickey rourke beaucoup moins maintenant
clair que maintenant
enfin je trouve qu'il ya de tels mauvais
choix de carrière etc
que fait du coup il en perd sa séduction
initial tu as vu combien de fois notre
semaine mais bien quatre fois quatre
fois oui facile bernard henri lévy tu
trouves que sexy je les trouvais là oui
je te trouvais vraiment extrêmement
attirant quand on a commencé à le voir
enfin je sais pas quel âge ils pouvaient
avoir vers vers la trentaine je trouvais
absolument extraordinaire oki doki
trouve sexy bâti trop sexy oui et puis
toi bien entendu bien gentil tu as dit
que tu es même côté féminin d'un homme
jaime l'ambiguïté ouais ouais j'aime
qu'une femme ne soit pas féminine à 100%
et j'aimerais un canal ne soient pas
masqués ont aidé les virils viril cette
laisse froid schwarzenegger oui oui oui
c'est dû à ton père tu crois
[Rires]
peut-être je ne sais je ne sais pas
parce que j'ai pas bien connu mon père
je mets mais c'est peut-être dû à ma
propre ambiguïté si on est un petit peu
ambigu soi même on a besoin de ça aussi
chez l'autre chedhomme tu veux tout tu
as dis toujours ah bon sa beauté
extérieure la beauté intérieure
ah bah oui ça diminue les chances oui
c'est parfait c'est pour ça qu'il va un
très grand chose on va faire une
interview oui non oui non pardon voilà
tout est dit et bien oui ou non non tu
es oui et non est ce que si tu le
tromper dutronc jacques tu dirais c'est
le fait est ce que tu qui traite tous
pour le grand amour
la maison tout manar thomas et les
grands oui est-ce que tu préfère avoir
des rapports sexuels dans le noir dans
la pénombre ou en pleine lumière
comme si on appelait nombre des membres
mais oui est ce que tu vas me faire
l'amour ailleurs que dans un lit pas
trop nous n'ont pas trop finement
émincées bio potes c'est celui des
revues pornos non ah bon sagem et lui
plaît girl byron non ouais tu regardes
des cassettes pornos ça m'est arrivé là
ça va plus ça dépend ça dépend des
acteurs ah bon parce que tu sais pas ce
que c'était
est ce que tu peux tout faire si tu
aimes les choses les trucs les plus
terribles tu vas rire tout ça si tu
préfères les plus simples sexuellement
c'est là où tu veux en venir
non non ben voilà c'est clair et on le
sait est ce que tu es déjà allé dans un
peep show non continuer je ne sais pas
ce que tu as déjà utilisé les
instruments
tu veux dire ouais non je m'oblige pas à
dire ils sont assurés n'ont jamais fâché
peut-être 28 je n'ai pas de souvenir
récent déjà eu des expériences
homosexuelles
oui avec dave a déjà vu des expériences
sado maso
oui à tes lecteurs dienstag sexe des
rencontres un gars sont immédiatement
partis ensemble faire la mode comme ça à
brûle pourpoint ça ne m'est pas encore
arrivé c'était pas encore nanti voix
brisée reviennent ça pourrait arriver à
notre époque c'est un peu délicat
difficilement quoique je suis à cheveux
est assez rapide mais bon on affronte
dans la seconde pour quelques jours
quant au rayon de sites étaient
surprises jeu par un soir jacques pas
rentrer à la maison et lula port eelv
avantage sans métaux voient qu'une fille
tu aurais honte
il lui serait absolument enchanté
justement j'en fais je refuse de lui
accorder
est ce que si c'était un travesti très
encore plus grande
ça alors franchement ça ça ne dit pas
dans le show zaborska ou parce que c'est
vraiment c'est le côté alors c'est pas
tenter tout ça non mais c'est à dire que
c'est à la fois c'est malsain et
grotesque moyens que j'aurais vraiment
envie de rire donc ça gâche tout
[Applaudissements]
mardi dont soir bonsoir c'est la vraie
chasse et je suis sûr que vous
connaissez et daniel prévost
je vous embrasse pour mon fils et mon
mari qui vous adore et moi je suis
toujours l'équipe à gentilly ces cas les
oliviers à peine avec celle tale of law
françois je suis sûr vous n'êtes pas du
tout contente des chansons que j'ai
choisi a quand même y en avait deux ou
trois qui je sais que la première en
tous les cas vous l'avez pas du tout
mais les autres ça va je suis un petit
peu fatigué mais c'est normal
oui comment ça va ça va vous avez la
floride veut revoir et moi aussi je très
heureux de vous voir sérieusement
alors vous avez vous êtes très critique
sur vos premiers niveaux les réécouter
jamais ils parient sur les derniers
aussi en tout cas il ya une chanson de
vous qui sort actuellement et qu'on
écoutera encore dans dix ans dans les
émissions de télévision
magnéto serge
mais il la remercie en le raccompagnant
sérieusement regarder les journaux fait
six yards
originalité c'est vrai savez-vous nous
nous séparons pour la première fois
vraiment faim c'est pas toi moi et puis
par que quinze jours un tout petit peu
dois-je comprendre que vous allez passer
ses 15 horrible le jour sans compter les
heures
puisque vous partez en voyage
puisque nous
nous quittons ce soir
mon coeur fait son apprentissage
j'adore
je veux sourires avaient cours
ja
[Musique]
aux bagages
j'avoue
du coup droit
les rangs juniors
je vais préparer mon
homo juin
[Musique]
instant le train démarre
resterait seul sur lequel
[Musique]
et vous
avec votre book
prométhée nous
être bien saint jean
[Musique]
pas certain
tous les jours
j'ai retourné
[Musique]
plaisantant
le single et l'album duquel ce single
est extrait je n'en reviens pas
incroyable on la pas et ça pour moi
c'est la définition de la classe voilà
tous les deux classes la chanson c'est
d'abord la chanson qui est magnifique
touche en 1935 la chanson c'est une
chanson de gens savent c'est une chanson
de jeu de jambes on y est chanté par
jean sablon
alors qu'est ce qui a changé entre la
version de l'époque et la version
d'aujourd'hui parce que là dans le clip
qu'on vient de voir c'est vous qui
commencez alors que dans l'extrait que
j'aime pas cessé ou jean sablon qui
commanda parce que mireille était
quelqu'un c'est une espèce de lutins
très très fantasque plein d'humour etc
je trouvais que ça correspondait mieux à
jacques aussi d'être la personne qui
s'en va et moi amoureuse transie qui
restent sur le quai mais il n'a pas été
satisfait à 100% puisqu'il a tenu à ce
qu'on refasse cette chanson pour son
propre album qui n'est pas encore prêt
et où c'est lui qui reste sur le quai et
moi leur parler un peu du cd là
cada sais pas monsieur cas du suma bravo
vous avez sur ces gars-là à zurich
alors si une entreprise familiale il ya
le duo avec jacques dutronc qui votre
mari il ya votre fils qui joue de la
guitare
les photos de l'album ont été faites par
votre premier amour jean marie périer
c'est vraiment mieux
oui mais enfin bon c'est pas comme ça
pour toutes les chansons quand même il
ya beaucoup de reprises qui sont très
bien d'ailleurs on va en parler mais
pourquoi vous trouvez qu'il ya un manque
de talent dans l'écriture des chansons
en ce moment vous mais c'est vrai que au
moment où je devais m'attaquer à la
conception à la préparation de cet album
j'avais certaines chansons inédites et
donc il m'en fallait d'autres et les
mélodies que j'ai reçus ne m'inspirait
pas vraiment et et donc je me suis dis
plutôt que plutôt que de s'acharner sur
des mélodies qui n'en valent peut-être
pas la peine
il vaut mieux aller vers le patrimoine
et je ne savais pas que au même moment
des tas d'autres chanteurs chanteuses
non seulement en france mais aussi en
angleterre j'établis août par tous
avaient la même idée alors là vous êtes
très en forme vous êtes très vieux airs
très très gai tout ça
l'album est pas terrible ça part et ça
me fait très plaisir l'album est pas
terriblement guerre mais jamais jamais
jamais
les belles mélodies ne sont pas gays
alors justement vous avez dit moi une
belle mélodie guillou
c'est vrai que big bisou c'est bien
alors justement françoise hardy a repris
une phrase célèbre pour parler de son
album vous dit pas les chants désespérés
sont les plus beaux sait de qui enfin je
veux dire je connais là je connais
parfaitement cette cette citation ou
fait mais je vais vous citer la la
formule de prêt vert s'est lassé les
chants désespérés sont les chants les
plus beaux chants en commun des mortels
qui sont de pures sanglots et jacques
prévert a écrit dans paroles ou dans
l'histoire les chats désespérés sont les
chants du pied bot il me semble me
souvenir que c'est alpha de musiciens
des bus et qui a dit li qui a dit
l'humour est la politesse du désespoir
c'est le capitaine l'aigle ou non sa
capitaine
non c'est pas les bons dans les trucs
comme ça françoise littérature les
archives pour la politesse du désespoir
l'humour est la politesse surya bonaly
en 82 non après un double axel aux gens
c'est lui qui a dit ça aujourd'hui
savoir qui a dit vous pouvez détruire
tout ce qu'il vous plaira elle n'aura
qu'un ou six cabrel à la brave vaut
mieux qu'elle
[Applaudissements]
les bouquins cela et les corps et on
reconnaît qu'après si la montée jusqu
alors j'ai cité la phrase en entier
parce qu'elle est très belle 1 vous
pouvez détruire tout ce qu'il vous
plaira elle n'aura qu'à ouvrir l'espace
de sela bras pour tout reconstruire hier
si je suis désolé est-ce que ça va
permettre de dire que c'est aussi
beaucoup c'est qu'il ya des chanteurs
qui écrivent des textes que vous aurez
de la littérature française après hors
saison et une très belle fiction songe
au sujet des mélodies au sujet des
textes est là je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'elle dit il ya de
très très belles chansons qui sont de
pur chef-d'oeuvre au niveau du texte
oui ça c'est la vérité et moi je vais
vous dire la parole ces paroles
d'évangile les paroles de ses chansons
de léo ferré sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
bien sûr chef-d'oeuvre l'avantagent de
daniel prévost c'est qu'ils donnent du
contenu à lui nuire à la sas est formé
d'un coup vous l'a plombé plus tard
tu es là pour ça daniel moi ça m'a
beaucoup plu l'histoire de mon amie la
rose que vous chantiez je suis désolé de
vous dire peut-être que ça vous plaît
pas mais c'est une très très jolie
chanson et vous l'avez très très bien
chanter maintenant donnez moi de
l'argent je continue
[Rires]
alors que vous avez déclaré klose a
redit ce qui est passé ne reviendra plus
et une phrase terrible non mais une
phrase non tu très fort tant la pallice
alors n'attendez dont il ya un truc
terrible à dire que pour vous qui avez
incarné comme vous êtes la génération
qui a incarné l'adolescence quand on lit
des phrases comme ça puis pure n'est pas
loin d'avoir le même âge vous dites il
ne me reste plus que 30 fois à voir
fleurir les lilas c'est vrai que con
quand on compte la vie en année on voit
fleurir les lilas ou autre chose c'est
ridicule même sans fois avoir bondi pas
jusqu'à s'entend mais sans fois voir
fleurir l'insee réunion mais c'est vous
qui plombe l émission c'est terrible oui
mais là c'est bien là tout va bien faire
plus et en raison des mails aux complots
de très bonne qualité un bravo moi j'ai
bouffé série sortiront ça vous
travaillez sur françoise hardy j'ai
réfléchi pourquoi vous êtes un peu comme
on dit l'âme en peine
j'ai trouvé trois raisons la première
raison on va pas s'étendre là dessus on
est capricorne tous les deux si vous
êtes capricorne êtes saturnienne eric a
pas que moi j'ai pas saturne et jupiter
je trouvais capricorne ne sont pas
saturés d'accord vous êtes anxieux
angoissés vous êtes ermite face à ces
traits capricorne ya un vous vivez dans
un bunker il paraît maintenant 16e
arrondissement en face à françoise hardy
quand on lui parle de meilleures
vacances qu'elle pourrait passer elle
dit ses seuls à paris au mois d'août
s'agit oui c'est vrai ou alors seul dans
corse enfermé dans ma chambre avec 40
bouquin grand plaisir lire au lit va
encore me relis non non non non mais si
oui oui non mais c'est pour ça que je
sens que j'ai pas besoin de voyager aux
premières raisons de votre recherche par
l'esprit effectifs saturnienne deuxième
raison votre grand mère
c'est vrai qu'au trot mais elle nous a
pas aidés françoise non mais bien
entendu qu'on est bronzée au dernier
degré mais nous sommes tous vous savez
oui ma grand mère était avec une
poitrine énorme et elle avait des jambes
très courte et donc elle a passé son
temps à me dire que j'étais affreuse
devient droit l'indre c'est pour ça que
je ne vais pas imiter j'ai arrêté le
développement de soi
des démentis disait qu'elle avait un
gros ventre c'est pas ça quand même un
truc génial c'est qu'elle vous disait
elle vous parlez toujours des mecs avec
une espèce de thon c'en est un peu
hystérique votre grand-mère faut dire
les choses
bon enfin c'était une autre génération
en génération
en parlant des mecs elle vous par action
de la chose la chose est alors je me
souviens d'une chanson de vous que
j'adore qui s'appelle twingo précis vous
dites mon mari m'a fait la chose
aujourd'hui c'est honteux
comment est-ce que jonas michel gabriel
yared des gens des artistes de cette
trempe ont pu se [__] de moi de cette
phase
mon mari m'a fait la chanson j'aime
laisser faire ces magnifiques cette
chance aux bleus mais face swing au
pressing vous aimez pas c'est un
monument de la chanson france annonce
est vrai nom se connaissaient pas je
voulais dire moi alors sérieusement le
seul couple gay qui ait duré aussi
longtemps finalement yeah yeah yeahs
comment ça se fait à votre avis comme ça
je pense que c'est parce qu'on est
terriblement casanier ou détestent la
nouveauté les champs nouveau tout ça
mais est-ce que c'est pas parce que tu
es
non mais sérieusement est-ce que c'est
pas parce que dès le départ sérieusement
parce que j'essaye de trouver le bonheur
comme tout le monde on va en parler avec
eux vous heureusement depuis un service
devant justement mener dans une certaine
presse a fait j'essaie justement
programme de marche
oui je me dis que dutronc vous a imposé
un petit peu la même chose c'est-à-dire
que les amis passionnés d'histoire ont
marre et on attend dans notre couple
ça marche très bien mais vous marchez
tout le temps vous dites je devais
savoir pourquoi mon couple marche vous
marchez tout le temps nous arrêter
j'approchais
monsieur prévost je suis marié geof est
ce que le est-ce que c'est pas ça excuse
sérieusement est-ce que le fait est
qu'il a mis tout de suite dé distant
louis marc faget est-ce que c'est pas ça
qui a préservé votre bien sûr que c'est
une recette qui marche pour pour
certaines personnes bien sûr que le
couple est une affaire condamné plus ou
moins à l'avancé que la façon de le
faire durer le plus longtemps possible
c'est de ne pas être dans une
promiscuité trop importante ou pas trop
focaliser sur l'autre c'est sûr et mais
c'est des lapalissades aussi bon non non
les gens ne s'y attendait les gens les
gens les dépenses au foyer base et le
couple il ya des couples qui sont frères
et soeurs y en a d'autres qui sont
amants maîtresse on a d'autres qui sont
permis tout dépend sur quoi ces bases et
si on aime si si c'est basé sur sur le
désir c'est sûr que il faut éviter la
promiscuité voilà c'est pas vous vivez
ensemble
vous avez vécu ensemble aux visions se
pose est ce que voulait dire présent
vous avez vécu sa part un habitant
vaguement d'accord ils avaient chacun
votre vote voilà ils ont chacun un état
comme j'aime tellement bon d'accord qui
ont abandonné on va avoir donné votre
couple je suis désolé parce que je pense
qu'il ya plein riche en silice
il ya plein de choses que vous pouvez
par votre exemple apprendre à des jeunes
coup plusieurs générations je suis
content mais j'espère que nous érigeons
à une statistique montant du moment mais
vous avez su préserver votre amour et ça
dure depuis longtemps sous-entend donc
pas moi su préserver un rôti de veau
pendante
oh
[Applaudissements]
puisque c'est comme ça vous croyez aux
astres on va faire une interview
croyances on bouge quand le jingle on
veut bouger par le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas pascal bruckner je crois qu'ils
avaient péri vous êtes brune est requis
pascal keller réception c'est bien je
lui dis c'est bruner qui vient aider bon
ben c'est bruckner va parler du bonheur
justement moi je suis en colère mais j'y
arrive pas est ce que vous voyez est ce
que vous croyez à l'amour oui bien c'est
même ce qui est plus important parce que
tout ce qui va mal dans le monde vient
de gens qui dans leur enfance
on était carencée en amour authentique
parce qu'il ya plein de falsification de
l'amour même il ya des tas de parents
qui n'aiment pas leurs enfants
enfin il croit qu'il est mais en fait
ils ne l'aiment pas et je vous voyais en
vous c'est fluctuant
je croyais en dieu
dieu c'est un mot mais mais ce qu'il ya
derrière ce mot oui est ce que vous
croyez au hasard finalement pas tant que
ça pas tant que ça est ce que vous
croyez au petit signe du destin par
exemple frédéricton raconter tout à
l'heure son rêve elle était sur un taxi
avec sony naceri ya pascal bruckner et
non bruner dans l'émission oui sinon est
ce que vous croyez aux mauvais esprits
avec un s à des caennais mais il ya des
théories qui sont très intéressantes qui
veulent que que certains êtres qui sont
morts donc et qui sont restés trop
attaché au matériel à la matière reste
très proche de la terre et sont assez
néfaste
je sais pas ce que ça vaut gardiens je
ne sais pas je crois je crois qu'il ya
des forces invisibles qui nous qui
peut-être nous protège je pense
les guides et aussi par
on est guidé par ce que l'on peut croire
à des choses sans rentrer dans des trip
mystique ou quoi mais c'est aussi ce qui
nous fait ce qui nous fait avancer tous
les jours je sais que je crois aux jo je
crois aux gens qui a raison de vous on
vous ont aimé même s'ils sont plus là et
le fait de vous vous continuez à les
aimer ça vous fait avancer donc je pense
pas il me regardant au moyen mais moi je
continue à aimer sûr là je parle par
exemple pour une personne appréciée
aujourd'hui vous croyez à la télépathie
ah oui je pense qu'il peut y avoir
effectivement l'homéopathie ah oui j'y
crois aussi bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez là comme récompense pour avoir
bien répondre à toutes ces questions
vous voulez le triomphe romain la forêt
vous aimez la forêt marie laforêt non la
forêt partir dans la forêt la forêt oui
vous voulez partir dans la forêt vous
allez fermer les yeux ça dépend si c'est
la forêt non c'est non pas du tout c'est
une forêt très calme c'est votre boulot
n'y a là rien chez vous si les yeux est
ce que tout le monde peut fermer les
yeux sur le plateau chez eux
fermez les yeux tout le monde ferme les
yeux fermés les yeux on part en forêt
chez moi chez moi
rien dire et un viol
voilà c'était notre petite minute dans
la forêt ça vous a plu
voilà on est tous milieux non n'est ce
pas monsieur prévost mais moi j'aime
beaucoup c'est bien la forêt oui j'ai
reconnu notre petit oiseau voici
françoise hardy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
ça va très heureux nous avons avec nous
alors françoise hardy double actu donc
d'abord un livre qui s'appelle les
rythmes du zodiaque
c'est au cherche midi
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est pour le liban il ya aussi
un indice c'est un best-of qui s'appelle
message personnel c'est chez virgin
[Musique]
alors à commencer par le disque donc
c'est une compilation mais qui a une
particularité c'est que les morceaux ont
été choisis par vous pour une fois
d'habitude c'est les patrons des maisons
de disques qui font ça sans vous en
parler sans vous en parler voilà oui
donc j'ai choisi des chansons qui ne
sont pas tellement connu du public et
qui à mon avis sont aussi bonne sinon
meilleur que ça qu'ils sont plus connu
des grosses tu donc genre il ya des gros
trucs genre comment te dire adieu partir
quand même si jamais entendu ça de ma
vie lors comment te dire adieu je ne
sais pas c'est le simplement vers moi
partir quand même laurent givet de
françoise hardy
ça me revient par bribes vous les
copains je ne vous oublierai jamais
voilà et puis alors il ya des chansons
moins connues effectivement comme le
crabe
tu connais il a le crâne dans le cra
vallées martien des chansons qui ont
fait que françoise hardy devenu une
icône culte chez les jeunes musiciens
chez le jeune chanteur a commencé par
etienne daho blur aussi tu sais que les
mecs de blur sont fans de de françoise
demi ce merveilleux je me suis
démissionnaire ce moment soit un si
jeune que ça bill pritchard to be free
tout le monde adore france
mais c'est ça c'est partir un jour
groupe
leveaux père si vous adorent r oui j'ai
d'ailleurs enregistré une chanson avec
eux voilà c'est dingue
si vous êtes bien que la marianne
faithfull de française oui mais en mieux
non plus je dis pas non plus ma petite
odyssée reconnaissent que vous partez en
voyage
puisque nous
quittant ce soir
[Musique]
mon coeur fait son apprentissage
des jeunes
je veux sourire avec ou
je
pour les
vos bagages
marche avant
du coup droit
non
pour les grands signes ou des hommes
je vais préparer
maugeois puisque avoue partir en voyage
françoise hardy cédant message personnel
la quantité la telma
il s'appelle la mecque et avec elle son
look ne sais pas mais j'ai le nom bout
de la langue
il s'appelle je sais pas il va sortir un
disque bientôt d'ailleurs
oui c'est imminent alors deuxième
actualité de françoise hardy donc le
livre les rythmes du zodiaque c'est au
cherche midi
alors on va prendre les choses dans
l'ordre parce que c'est vrai que c'est
l'astrologie des fois ça peut sembler un
peu compliqué alors ça avec moi ça l'est
et donc quand on vous demande sur quoi
est basée l'astrologie françoise hardy
vous dit tout se passe comme si le
système nerveux du nouveau-né fixer les
rythmes de son environnement solaire au
moment précis de sa naissance de son
environnement solaire c'est le système
solaire bien entendu les gens sont
tellement cons donc c'est ça quand on
est quand on quand on arrive comme ça au
jour à ce moment là on sait comme une
empreinte voilà c'est ça c'est comme ça
ça semble se passer c'est clair que ça a
le mérite d'être clair il sans
conviction que georges et ses dires au
contraire je n'ai pas manège me dire il
quand on est dans le monde pourquoi on
serait pas soumis aussi à l' influence
cela pourrait il faut attendre de sortir
du vent n'a pas ce qu'on reçoit
directement il ya plus la protection de
la maman oui c'est vrai
ce filtre c'est alors le problème le
problème c'est que depuis plusieurs
siècles l'astrologie est pratiqué par
des astrologues qui ne connaissent rien
reste rhône au mit
j'étais sûr qu'on parlera d'elisabeth
tessier et ça arrive et ça c'est vrai ça
et je n'y connaissais rien les mecs au
départ l'astrologie était pratiquée par
des astronomes et un certain moment elle
a été interdite
du coup elle est tombée dans les mains
de gens qui se sont contentés les
symboles astrologique et sans sans
spécialement on en met sans savoir que
ça recoupe est réellement sans savoir
pourquoi on utilisait ses symboles et il
a fallu attendre le 20e siècle le milieu
du xxème siècle pour que surgisse comme
par miracle
jean pierre nicolas qui ici se sentent
bull depuis qu'accor ça fait 30 ans que
non mais c'est le seul qui a fait
avancer l'astrologie depuis depuis
plusieurs siècles
non mais la seule chose qu'il faut
préciser c'est que l'astrologie informe
sur l'un de nos conditionnements qui est
justement conditionnement seles c'est à
dire la situation du système solaire au
moment de notre naissance laquelle se
résume à des rythmes et les quel rythme
nous prédispose à avoir certains
réflexes par rapport au monde paraît par
exemple capricorne dont vous êtes et a
tendance à tendance à avoir un réflexe
de fermeture par rapport au monde alors
que les gémeaux que vous êtes aussi
tendance au contraire c'est ça qui les
donnent un côté et changer ça
quelles sont sony vous savez energimo et
vous ça marche mais sont très
complémentaires y en a un qui peut
sécuriser l'autre puis l'autre qui peut
mettre en danger l'un donc c'est
nécessaire autant à la classe une
affaire qui peut qui peut tourner ce
dont je me rends compte c'est qu'à
chaque fois tu façon il ya toujours
quelque chose à dire vie évidemment on
vous dit que le fait que ce soit
capricorne et lui gémeaux je ne sais
plus vierge j'aime bien j'aime au 6 mai
s'est confié nicole temps ça va ensemble
ça veut tout dire mais non mais non mais
c'est là on retombe dans les trucs non
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut être
beaucoup plus précis que ça vaut la
vierge à l'aidant l'autoprotection donc
à lalanne indépendant par la laddh a des
réflexes sécuritaires de de fermeture
romande besoin de se protéger par
rapport il ya les battre le contraire ou
dix ans oui c'est sur ascendant balance
soit sans danger mot retraite dans la ma
vie vous êtes beaucoup mieux qu'il avait
testée mais je suis patient parce que
avec vous c'est très difficile devrait
s'exprimer pour la première fois je me
sens très solidaire des abbés plus alors
françoise hardy il ya une chanson de
vous que vous détestez
non mais
du
jean mi
il
ils font soit à redire on va vous faire
une interview tous les garçons et filles
de mon âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françoise est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles de votre âge vous
regarder des chiffres et des lettres
absolument est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles votre âge vous
regrettez les années 60
non je regrette les années à venir que
je ne vivrai pas
vous avez dit un truc terrible jour j'y
pense sans elle m'a dit un truc un jour
elle m'a dit genre il nous reste
puisqu'on a perdu pratiquement le même
âge tu te rends compte qu'il nous reste
peut-être que 20 noël ou vingt fois à
voir fleurir les lignes chaque fois ça
m'a fait flipper j'y pense tous les
jours je me dis 19 janvier
le trompe la mort il se risque même ça
c'est pas mal françoise hardy est ce que
comme tous les garçons et les filles de
votre âge d'être fan de jacques dutronc
j'ai prouvé je crois qu est-ce qu il
devient le lion nathan est ce que comme
tous les garçons et les filles votre âge
de les prendre votre retraite sur la
côte d'azur
mais c'est déjà fait est ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
vous portez des thermolactyl de damart
tous les hivers papa ce soir est ce que
comme tous les garçons et les filles de
votre âge vous raconter toujours les
mêmes histoires à table gens racontent
aucunement gpra votre localité
est ce que comme tous les garçons et
filles de votre âge j'avais les jambes
lourdes en fin journée confirme comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
est ce que vous avez arrêté de vous
droguer non mais je vais peut-être
commencer bientôt
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge qu'on soit zardi
vous lisez la rubrique nécrologique
avant l'horoscope
ça me rappelle emmanuel berl qui qui
voyait d'un très mauvais oeil mon
intérêt pour l'astrologie qui me
disaient j'ai lu mon horoscope
aujourd'hui était déjà très très âgé et
me dit on me conseille de prendre
conseil justement de gens plus âgés mais
y'en a plus qu est-ce que comme tous les
garçons les filles de votre âge et
susceptibles quand on vous parle de
votre âge ça vous dérange pas non moi je
le jure mais 85 ans c'est pour ça
bonsoir des vilains messieurs donc le
livre que je vous recommande s'appelle
les rythmes des zodiac et sérénité au
cherche midi
quant au disque qui s'appelle message
personnel et c'est chez vertige
j'accueille françoise hardy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir oui mesdames messieurs les
enfants 13 ans pas si je m'appelais
françoise hardy pouvoir essayer
astrologiquement c'est un bon jour pour
faire la loi contrairement à ma
concurrente directe je ne consulte pas
eh bien non c'est un très mauvais jour
pour faire la promo de cet album france
peut-être peut-être y sont rares et
est-ce que d'après les à ce sera un
album qui pourrait marcher sans promo
oui ça je ne sais pas si c'est le genre
de question qu'il faut poser aux as
alors l'album de françoise hardy
s'appelle tant de belles choses et il
sera en vente eu mardi
c'est un album totalement inédit le
dernier album totalement inédite
contrats c'était aux habitants
s'appelait le danger 1 ces vraies
questions pendant huit ans vit dans non
mais j'en ai fait entre temps il y avait
moitié de chansons il ya la crise je
suis allé vraiment inédit un oui et vous
l'avez réalisé avec benjamin biolay
alain lubrano non non non je n'ai pas
rien benjamin biolay c'est ce que mon
fils n'arrête pas de me dire tu as pas
pour toi si tu lui dis un truc non
françoise hardy est ce que vous racontez
bon alors évident bien non non mais
benjamin biolay
ma porte est une chanson il ya trois ans
mais sa chanson été réalisés précisément
par monsieur thomas dutronc
donc c'est pas lui qui a réalisé sa
chanson pour une fois d'accord
bon ça c'est fait alain lubrano alain
lubrano oui il m'a mené plusieurs
chansons formidable et il m'a dit tu
devrais faire un album comme ça et je me
suis trouvée d'un seul coup avec ces
trois chansons avec deux chansons que
thierry stremler m'avait envoyé et voilà
j'ai déjà dit à l'étrier j'avais plus
qu'à jacno aussi jacno ça c'est moi
qu'ils accordent à ces normes et jacno
il il avait il avait un instrumental que
je trouvais génial sur son dernier album
et je trouverai je trouvais que celui
qui était sur votre répondeur de
téléphone c'est pas lui c'est juste bien
française donc jacno il y avait un
chemin et thomas dutronc le fameux
thomas dutronc
oui tu as beaucoup travaillé sur cet
album il a pas mal travaillé sur cet
album il m'a amené des musiciens
exceptionnels et lui-même a fait
quelques solos de guitare que je trouve
alors vraiment fantastique c'est bien
c'est thomas dutronc vous dit il et j'ai
la chance vous dites il est doux il
doute
il aime les mélodies nostalgiques comme
moi oui comme beaucoup de gens ses
mélodies nostalgiques que vous écoutez
inlassablement sur lesquels vous mettez
des mots formidable en général
d'ailleurs mais c'est très très
difficile de trouver des mélodies
aujourd'hui parce qu on a eu tellement
qui ont été faites et c'est presque
aussi difficile de trouver des mots qui
n'ont pas été trop trop dit de tout et
des îles
un tout petit peu différente ne serait
ce que par rapport à ce qu'on a fait soi
même déjà auparavant
voilà c'est difficile quand tu fais
qu'un métier
le père de thomas dutronc est emballé un
bas il est il était emballé par la
chanson tant de belles choses que je
vais fait entendre à la ccc petit son
père c'est un ami alors on va revenir
aux autres chansons après mais d'abord
je voudrais commencer par le single qui
s'appelle justement le temps de belles
choses comme l'album alors c'est
l'histoire d'une personne qui doit
partir qui s'adresse à un enfant un ami
un amant ce n'est pas vraiment et qui
tente de le consoler avec des idées pose
ici voilà j'ai toujours été intéressé
par par la spiritualité sur par le sens
de la vie qu'est ce qu'on fait là pour
qu'on est là et c'est et j'ai toujours
eu l'impression bon c'est peut-être très
banal ce que je vais dire mais que que
la mort c'est qui est certainement un
moment très pénible pour tout le monde
sauf pour les gens qui meurent en
dormant peut-être c'est la libération de
l'esprit qui est libéré subitement dû
subitement parfois très lentement du
matériel du physique et qui va dans un
autre espace temps et je pense que à
partir du moment où il ya des liens très
forts entre les êtres
le fait que l'un des deux que quelqu'un
meure avant avant les êtres qu'il aime
ne détruit pas le lien simplement le
corps n'est plus là mais l'esprit est là
ailleurs je crois ça vous croyez aux
forces de l'esprit
je crois à l'existence de l'esprit
[Musique]
je suis
vous connaissez orlando commissaire de
police est absolument qu'ils exigent
clip vous allez qui s'occupent de moi
si vous regardez votre caméra et vous
dites
magnéto serge alors magnéto
cache plus
[Musique]
g
les montagnes
la science se plaint
je ne
[Musique]
tant de belles choses extraits de son
nouvel an
tant de belles choses
ça m'a donné un boost l'eau il ya une
autre chanson qui s'appelle côté jardins
et côté cour
alors là ça dit il ya toujours le temps
qui courent et moi qui court après vous
oui mais ça a été vrai pendant longtemps
je suis obligé parfois de me rabattre
sur ma vie passée salut - aujourd'hui
évidemment vous du coup aurait pu après
aujourd'hui non non non il est
tranquille sur son lit regarde à moitié
à moitié infirme enfin bon non non
j'exagère
non non c'est plus d'actualité deviner
martigny et qu'il était donc vous
raconter tout ça mais je suis motivé et
on la connaît par coeur mais absolument
très intéressant et elle est développée
en long et en large dans les livres de
michel les miennes absolument voilà vous
dites que jacques dutronc vous adresser
la solitude absolument absolument parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui pendant des
années étaient relativement absents et
même quand il est là il a quelque chose
d'un petit peu alors je sais que
certains font d'un psy canalise un peu
cheap avec ça mais bon ça c'est valable
quand même aussi un peu pour un père
absent mari absent
si j'avais toujours eu l'espoir de le
voir plus souvent et puis finalement un
jour vous avez pris votre parti vous
êtes dit oui mais ces mêmes c'est même
pas ça quand je dis qu'il m'a adressées
à la solitude c'est c'est que j'ai été
forcé à assumer assurer une certaine
solitude et que finalement j'ai pris
goût et que je pense que si j'y ai pris
goût
c'est parce qu'elle correspondait aussi
à ma nature profonde que je ne savais
pas au départ alors pour le menacer vous
lui disiez un jour tout ça me fera ni
chaud ni froid
et puis c'est arrivé je non mais c'est
pas ça c'est que quand le quand le temps
passe quand on connaît quelqu'un depuis
très très longtemps les
et sentiments évoluent c'est ce que tout
le monde dit c'est la vérité donc c'est
vrai qu'on passe de de la passion avec
tout ce que ça implique de possessivité
de jalousie d'exclusivisme on passe de
ça à une amitié très particulière très
particulière et finir la chanson
jardiniers bénévoles
ouais vous dites aimer l'autre c'est
laisser vivre oui mais ça c'est quelque
chose que je peux dire aujourd'hui qu'on
pensait déjà quand j'étais beaucoup plus
jeune mais que je n'aurais pas été
capable de faire parce que quand on est
amoureux et qu'on est jeunes on a envie
d'avoir l'autre pour soi et on fait tout
pour l'avoir à soi et en même temps
qu'on fait tout pour l'avoir à soit on
fait exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
faut faire parce que évidemment ce qu'il
faut faire c'est le laisser le laisser
vivre le laisser libre et
effectivement dans cette chanson je dis
je parle d'envol quoi je parle d'ouvrir
les bras pour que l'autre puis on prenne
son envol et non pas pour l'étouffer un
petit peu plus dans la prison dans
laquelle on aimerait être enfermé avec
lui alors ça n'empêche pas les aventures
il ya une chanson qui s'appelle sur quel
volcan voilà c'est une relation
clandestine dangereuse cacher ouais
c'est un peu bon moi j'ai toujours été
fasciné par ça c'est pas vraiment
d'actualité par rapport à par rapport à
moi et à ma vie j'ai passé un petit peu
le cap par rapport à ces choses là mais
je sais pas pourquoi ça m'évoque le
signe parce que parfois je peux être
aspirés par des films ça m'évoque le
très beau fine de julve ce qui est
important c'est d'aimer
il ya une situation comme ça on vous
évoque rien de personnel non non non
vous n'avez jamais eu une aventure comme
sa secrète non page enfin en tout cas
parce que c'était tellement vrai si
personne ne sait si c'est arrivé c'est
comme mon agent perd la mémoire donc si
c'est arrivé j'ai oublié c'est un peu
dommage quand même c'est un peu dommage
quoi doucher les choses a pas avoir
connu ça je sais pas parce que je crois
que des situations comme ça c'est
beaucoup de souffrance pour tous
beaucoup de soucis beaucoup de soucis
beaucoup de souffrance c'est vous
préférez pas avoir de soucis qu'a voir
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui ans quand j'étais plus
jeune c'est ça m'est égal je foncer tête
baissée vers le danger alors c'est pas
toujours été facile avec dutronc et
pourtant vous aviez eu les plus grandes
stars à vos pieds moi je joue s'alarme
attendez attendez brian jones mick
jagger bob dylan c'est vrai quand même
françoise loeb dylan c'est vrai mais il
paraît
anne vilano 64 on est on est né en 64
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais si je te
dis à ce qui s'est passé
bob dylan en 64 tombe en arrêt devant
une photo de françoise hardy en
couverture de bugs fait par william
klein il en fait personne ne connaissait
bob dylan à l'époque il venait voir
hugues aufray hugues aufray voulait
adapter les chansons de bial en france
donc il a fait l'autre venait le voir et
deux ans plus tard il revient il est
dans sa loge à l'olympia il refuse de
monter sur scène tant qu'il n'a pas vu
françoise hardy quand même c'est vrai ça
ouais ouais gt gt
je les folles de baume de bob dylan
j'adorais ses chansons mon rêve c'était
de le voir sur scène il arrive à paris
pour chanter à ce moment là j'étais sur
un tournage avec yves montand on était à
monaco je suppliais john frankenheimer
de me laisser monter à paris pour le
concert de bob dylan et comme il devait
avoir des penchants un peu sadiques john
frankenheimer il m'a dit le dernier jour
ce moment là veulent m'a dit bon tu peux
aller tu peux aller à paris et puis la
grosse déception parce que bob dylan
n'était pas au meilleur de sa forme
vraiment c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et il a déçu les attentes du public
car c'était pas c'est pas très bon la
manière dont il a chanté dont il a joué
de la guitare et c est donc à l'entracte
il ne revenait pas puisqu'ils faisaient
les deux parties est quelqu'un est venu
me demander d'aller dans sa loge
parce que sinon il ne remontait pas sûr
voilà enfin je ne souviens absolument
pas de ce qui a pu se passer dans sa
loge moi j'étais terrifiée je veux une
espèce de vampires jaune avec avec des
des ongles trop la messe était aux
fraises moi je ne vous raconte pas c'est
qu'ensuite vous allez tu savais que
zouzou johnny hallyday hugues aufray et
vous au genre g5 bob dylan is not
complètement le johnny hallyday ouzou et
hugues aufray il vous prend vous dansez
dans sa suite voyage il me prouve toute
façon tu parles d'un tutorial et il vous
fait écouter just like a woman i want
you to
quand même deux plus grandes chansons
oui vous l'avez vous l'avez revu après
non non non mais c'est pas sinon je suis
et je sais j'ai su que récemment quand
il était à paris peut-être pas la
dernière fois mais l'avant dernière fois
leur genre demandé s'il avait mieux des
jeunes se maintenant je m'en tire sa
place il apprendra enfin bon je sais
qu'il a demandé de mes nouvelles
allez je préfère qu'il reste avec le
fantasme de la photo de mes 20 ans
plutôt que me voir que voir la ruine que
je suis devenu tour de la saisir comme
ça arrêtez vous un bon mais c'est passé
on passe à la radio
[Musique]
bonsoir vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
là je pense avoue thierry c'est quoi
vraiment pourquoi vous fait plein de
grimace avec votre bouche la section
oui j'ai remarqué qu'il a des dents
particulièrement étincelant
non pourquoi c'est vrai c'est pas des
conneries comme ça vous pensez y voit
couper ça au montage
c'est le moment le plus crucial dans
l'émission il me plaît de penser à quoi
la met à vous et à votre sourire colgate
a regardé par contre c'est garder au
montage
quand vous regardez le matin dans un
miroir vous vous dites quoi
non mais j'ai un miroir vraiment j'ai
déménagé et pas très très longtemps et
le miroir on voit rien donc ça va et en
plus quand j'ai pas mes lunettes je vois
encore moins bien donc je ne me dit rien
parce que ça va faire très attention je
vois pas vous auriez met à ressembler à
quelqu'un vous étiez petit ressembler à
qui quand j'étais petit mais figurez
vous que je collectionnais des photos
d'actrice est la première actrice que
j'ai trouvé d'une beauté sublime c'était
marina vlady elle était belle et je
crois qu'elle est toujours le théâtre
stb très très dur semble aller vers le
oui oui puis à mme bardot bien sûr et ma
mère qui m'avait acheté une
une robe en vichy rose qui ne m'allait
pas du tout c'est une catastrophe comme
gelée essayez vous seriez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour
non non parce que le grand amour est
derrière moi je ne pensais pas qu'on
puisse émettre deux fois dans sa vie à
nager mais plus que deux fois dans ma
vie ça ses premiers indices anna non
mais ça tout le monde le sait même plus
je suis zen jean marie périer il ya eu
un bel acteur anglais mais ça fait froid
qui s'est abattu on va faire je n'ai
jamais je n'ai pas joué ce soir chez lui
les jus de françoise hardy ah ouais jean
marie périer jagan tron est un acteur
anglais qui s'appelait anne ribes au
moment avec une vitalité mari voulait
pas divorcer et au moment où françois
pas du tout la question c'est que c'est
la question c'était pas ça pour lui gt
gt une aventure qu est ce que tu me
sentais très intéressant pour moi de
porter cette équipe cet acteur il est
connu et bien non non c'est un acteur
anglais jusqu'en du tsoup cités romeo
nous nous étions remontés
c'est au moment où il est il est et il
était vraiment pas mal du tout avec la
laverie c'était l'époque où jean marie
périer était un peu volage un peu un
finder jean marie périer n'a jamais été
volage il l'est devenu quand moi je les
suis
alors pourquoi vous êtes allés avec
l'anglais alors mais parce que parce
qu'il était à tomber alors en vain et
c'est là que dutronc enlevé ses lunettes
qu'il a mis des lentilles et qu'ils
veulent est beau c'est à ce moment là
non non non mais c'est à dire quoi je
suis resté un peu scotché c'est à cet
acteur anglais qui était très embêté que
parce que pour lui c'était pas il avait
n'avait jamais été question d'avoir une
relation suivie avec moi je crois que la
même année d'ailleurs
il a eu dans sa vie moi et brigitte
bardot il a fait plus fort que bob dylan
lui qui n'a eu ni l'une ni l'autre et
donc et qui les voulaient toutes les
deux à temps et donc donc cet acteur
très charmant me voyais temps en temps
avec avec jacky me disais mais il est
cent fois mieux que moi
il est cent fois mieux que moi c'est
avec lui qu'il faut être il avait raison
sa durée quand même temps mais sanaa ça
a été une aventure c'est très épisodique
ou à très épisodique mais très agréable
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois à quand je vois ce que je pensais
qu'il ya pas longtemps il ya eu un délit
terrible et je revenais de mes courses
avec mon quasi bourré mon panier bourg
etc
j'ai glissé sur une feuille je suis
retrouvé les quatre fers en l'air et
l'âge est là ça a été mon entraîneur fit
sienne dans le troisième âge est
vraiment génial
non vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique le cerveau et
oui oui je prendrai le cerveau je ne
sais pas moi détiennent emile baulieu
tiens
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous
je chante comme un pied c'est vrai et
même je chante moins bien qu'un pied je
suis d'accord je suis aussi alors si
votre vie était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil je serai je
serai moins dociles moins
et moi moi prévisible un peu plus
insaisissable coups sûrs voilà ça marche
tout le temps il faut nous surprendre il
faut être insaisissable faut ensuite
trier faut-il payer votre instinct mal
de conquêtes
oui tu as fait les courses et les noms
je sais pas fait wade s'en apercevoir sa
succession en dormant bah ouais bah
c'est pas moi ma belle mère est morte
dans son sommeil
alors c'est pas drôle évidemment pour la
personne qui se réveille à côté d'elle
mais froid
même chose
[Musique]
je vous trouve très enfants mois dernier
vous êtes venu là vous étiez un peu qu
est-ce qui c'était parce que la dernière
fois il fallait défendre quelque chose
de très compliqué et se trouvait dans
une émission comme ça où il faut mettre
un océan dans une petite bouteille c'est
très difficile dans cette présente plus
cher thierry que vous n'aviez pas lu une
seule ligne de mon livre et que vous
m'avez donc posé de très mauvaises
questions auxquelles il était très
difficile de reprendre et vraiment je me
suis sentie exactement n'a révoqué cette
d'elisabeth tessier
vous qui connaissez bien les des
planètes il ya de la vie et de la vie
sur jupiter vous croyez
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux